the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey you guys what's going on it's
Wednesday we're back again Wednesday
again we recovered from talking about
the greasy Strangler yesterday yeah and
today we're gonna take you
back off into the world of the
Paranormal for the weekend comes it's
hump day
every day is hump day for Tom
I somehow knew that you were good
sometimes we take you to the Stars take
you to the damn crime scenes taking down
the you know the distant quarters of the
planet today we're going to take you
into the world of the Paranormal
this is Ghost planes right yeah ghosts
on a plane yeah go song planes like
Snakes on a Plane kinda the ghost yeah
yeah or at least kind of like well okay
now initially what was voted for on the
patreon thing was Ghost of flight 191
which is what we're going to talk about
I wasn't sure if there was enough info
there to
fill out a whole show so I'm gonna do
another case as well like another kind
of like haunting that had to do with a
commercial airliner so we're gonna talk
about flight 401 as well which is maybe
I don't know if it's slightly more
popular it was maybe more popular like
in the 70s and stuff there was like
urban legends about it because they made
like a TV movie there was like a book
that came out in the 70s yeah I remember
yeah yeah both of these happened in the
70s by the way thank you Trey what do
you say this is brilliant guys I love
the old TV movie The Ghost of Flight 401
yeah this is top tier quality
entertainment right here yeah you guys
are killing it thank you yeah this was
actually uh really really fun I think I
remember seeing the ghost but it's just
one ghost I think is the name of it the
ghost of Flight 401 because it was a
book that came out I think the book came
out in 1974. it's in my notes like but
it's way down at the bottom and then
they made a TV movie in either 1976 or
1978 and I remember a lot of people
being like creeped out but you know what
I'm saying yeah what it what nothing I'm
just looking Oh I thought you were true
I thought you were like looking at
something like getting getting
distracted I'm looking at that drink oh
I couldn't tell what you were looking at
so anyway maybe about time for y'all to
get underneath the covers
with your [__] little let with your
little tablet put your earbuds in
get your drink
and let's consider this uh haunted
airplanes can an airplane be haunted
well
that's well okay it's according to
Stephen King
[Laughter]
even a car can be haunted
and it could possess you
Stephen King is just kind of like
haunted yeah haunted hotel haunted house
plant have I done that yet has he done
that probably yeah he's written so much
stuff I haven't [__] been in bad
houses before and seen Poltergeist it
wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me if an
airplane in a car could be haunted
yeah the thing about this is technically
not okay well let's do like a quick
summation like flight 191 that's not
technically a haunted airplane that was
like a horrible horrible airplane crash
and then people reported ghosts and [__]
like afterward and also they're like in
the area and also there were like um
some people said that they had
premonitions too like about it like
before it happened so we'll get into
that flight 401 which like I said is
maybe better known I'm not really sure
like at least as far as paranormal [__]
goes that was the plane that crashed
into the Everglades and then they the so
the story went that they used parts from
that plane like in other planes like
that they had salvaged and then like
people would see like the dead pilot and
stuff like on other planes you know what
I mean yeah so there's that kind of
stuff so that's what it was there I mean
that's like technically a haunted plane
but the first one's not technically a
haunted plane it's a haunted plane crash
site I guess so there's that
all right so I'm trying to think of like
if there's any
shout outs
um probably not so much like on the live
stream but we have uh I have enabled
what do you call it super thanks super
thanks on the videos it's an awesome
concept it's yeah it well it's kind of
like essentially like it's a little tip
jar like that if you can't give stuff
like during the Super chat or some of
the videos that we've recorded there's
like a little uh thing it's like I think
it's like a little heart with a dollar
sign in it or some [__] like that but
they just started doing that like not
too long ago what that means is is that
if you miss the live stream and you
enjoy the show and you want to send us a
super chat but you can't because it's no
longer live
sent us a super thanks that's the TR
that's the tip jar and it all goes and
it all goes to Jenny
yeah well it goes to Jenny this is
Jenny's job I'm along just for a free
ride for me this is just entertainment
yeah I guess my money otherwise yeah
that's what I mean you are you already
got I'm here to freely [__] up Jenny's
show dude
the only one that would be mine would be
a boyfriend with amsr when I did my amsr
Channel all that dress up like [__]
men the merciless yeah amsr on you
although I'd still have to get some
money for that if I was the one like
like edited stuff I'd give you a cut I'd
give you a cut well thank you I
appreciate that because like I said it
is kind of like a lot of work you know
yeah I had to buy the costumes and [__]
yeah imagine me in a Ming costume
well yeah see he was talking earlier
about I have like a stripper Mig costume
oh okay yeah yeah abs and [__] well yeah
because you can't go around covered up
no you can't be covered up for Animals
Heaven forbidden hell no no no there's
too many women out there too many women
oh my God the end of the amsr I was
thinking about it though because I was
looking at other dudes Channel and
everything and they were all thanking
him you know what I mean for because oh
you know thank you so much for you to
have a strong bald male because he's
he's he he's he's jacked he's English
he's bald got a beard and everything and
women saying I was abused and it's nice
to see a big strong guy who's gentle and
[__] there's a lot of that [__] in there
so I'm I was like getting guilted
reading that [__] and I don't even have
my channel yet because I was going to be
[__] with people on it
yeah you'd have to like walk a fine I
had a lot of fun I mean you have to like
make it pretty clear that it was yeah
like not meant to be taken seriously
it's like because yeah like like I can
see yeah like some women that have been
like really traumatized by like dudes
that look like that like yeah you know
it's like wow it's nice to see like
somebody that looks like a big Bruiser
like is a nice person yeah I totally
understand that one guy one guy said man
it's good to see because his his wife or
girlfriend uh helps him on some of them
where she'll she's good looking too
she'll be basically nude and you just
see her back and she's got long hair and
he'll do like a back massage on her
while he's doing the amsr
and people are [__] going crazy for
that
and uh one of the comments was is like
uh dude said man I'm a ball guy too it's
good it's good to see a big bald guy uh
being all gentle and everything because
we got The Stereotype of either being
some kind of superhero or super villain
pretty much yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what you know you got that's kind of the
stereotypes yeah you know what I mean
yeah he's all tatted up and [__] you
gotta own it it's called what's it
called uh
soft speaking gentleman amsr
[Laughter]
some [__] like that that's so cute
I'll tear it up Michelle I love it I
love it yeah I mean I know it's a
stereotype that people that look like
you know the people who look like you
are [__] now I mean in your case
it's true because you kind of is an
indicator but
but I realize that not everybody looks
like that
I was an [__] before I looked like
that that's what I well yeah that's what
I was just gonna say it's like this it
doesn't have anything to do without you
look because you've always been an
[__] like as long as I've been
um Thompson
what is true
um Tom psych says I've had it up to here
with these [__] ghosts on this
[__] plane and yeah I knew yeah
yeah yeah uh Trey said is it based off
them reusing parts of that plane that
crashed into Everglades isn't it yeah
yeah at least that's how the story goes
um Zach said there's a Colorado haunted
train Story I Heard years after they
tore the tracks out and put a highway
and the ghost will show up in the back
of people's cars ooh I love stories like
that uh Trey also said I had a teacher
in high school whose parents were killed
in that Everglades crash holy [__]
anything like anything that's about
plane crashes is like super traumatic
for me and honestly doing all the um
research that I did about flight 191
because that one
you know they um there's like a lot of
documentaries about how they figured out
like what caused it and like while I was
watching these documentaries about what
caused it I was sitting there going well
I'm never flying again that's for sure
like I'm sure it's safe and the fact
that this horrible accident happened
which I'll get into actually helped make
it safer because they were like oh they
figured out but still like almost 300
people had to get killed and that's like
really sucky but it's like I mean I
don't like flying anyway like in the
best of times but this really did not
make me feel any better about it that's
for sure so yeah and well neither did
the flight 401 thing now some people
um flight 191 everyone was killed
um Flight 401 some people survived I
don't [__] know how they did
um because the plane was just
obliterated but uh yeah some people did
live through I think it was 75 people or
something like that like I said I'll
check it when I get to my notes at the
bottom but a bunch of people died too
but not everybody did I don't know how
anybody survived through that [__] but
scary uh Trey said yeah plane crashes
scare me too and I've done a lot of
flying in recent years all back and
forth to Detroit yeah I mean I used to
fly a few times a year and I always
hated it the weird thing about it is I
didn't really start flying in Planes
until I was probably in my early 20s and
um the first few times I flew it didn't
bother me even though I was flying like
over the [__] Atlantic Ocean
which I don't like because that's like
my two things that I hate flying and oh
of crash in the ocean and then you
survive and then you get eaten by sharks
no thanks
um there's two of my least favorite Ways
to Die
so but it didn't bother me the first few
times I did it but then like one flight
I don't know probably like the fifth or
sixth one I'd ever been on was just like
horrible like the turbulence was
horrible it was just there was storms
and it was just like really really bad
and it happened like only an hour or two
into like a nine hour flight so then I
had to sit there for seven eight more
hours on this [__] flight and I was
just like crawling up the [__] walls
I was like get me off this [__]
airplane oh my god I've flown a lot
helicopters and airplanes I've always
loved it even if it was [__] rough
and fast or the doors were open I just
always liked it I don't like it I loved
it the um
craziest air crash store I've ever heard
was and this is these this both these
people lived okay
and they were interviewing the guy
he was flying alone he's in the very
back of the plane
this must have been in the 70s or 80s
um because I was late 80s that that this
I heard this on TV
and sitting next to him
was a kid who was about 10 who was also
flying alone
and the plane was going down
and I don't remember what has happened I
think that they were going to have to
belly in the the uh the landing gear
wouldn't go down and they're having a
problem controlling the plane
and the little kid and everybody's
praying on the plane you know I mean
they had a whole the plane went out of
control I think it flipped a couple
times all kinds of [__] happens right
yeah yeah I'm just like freaking out
just like thinking about it this guy's
trying to take my worst nightmare this
Pilot's trying to [__] belly it in
onto the runway
and the little kid next to him says
we're gonna he says this is gonna crash
and we're gonna die it's gonna catch on
fire
and the guy was like I bet you this
kid's right
and uh
right in front of them because you know
it was in some of the planes in the very
very back there's the restroom a couple
of seats and then the emergency door
yeah right it was that kind of situation
and then right in front of him was the
[__] door
and he tells the kid he says you know
what we should do when the plane gets
low right before it hits the ground we
should open that door and jump out
and he says you want to and the kid's
like yeah
so they he was looking when it was
coming in he looked out the window and
when they were about 40 feet off the
ground and coming just just about
hitting the runway he grabbed the kid by
his arm and ran up and [__] knocked
the door open threw the kid out and then
he jumped out
and they both lived everybody else was
killed
in [__] caught on fire I wonder what
flight that was I've never found it in
the 80s they were the only survivors
they were all busted up though well yeah
but that's better than being dead yeah
it was probably going about 110 miles an
hour on Landing maybe about that 100
miles but you can survive that long of
the Fall yeah people have survived plane
crashes before or even ones that fell
out of the [__] Sky it's not they're
probably only you know it's unusual but
the tail was probably only 40 or 50 feet
off the ground yeah when it when they
jumped out you know you might break all
your oh yeah but everybody else burned
up
plane was [__] loaded with fuel
landed on his belly if I could you know
burned up yeah
that's like uh
yeah
Tom psych said they should have plain
seats where you're in an indestructible
hamster ball but for humans with a
built-in parachute see I might fly then
like
an escape pod or something
yeah that's maybe the only way I would
[__] do it like from from now for
like like I said I can read all the
things in the world about how it's the
safest method of transportation and
bloody bloody blah but I don't like
I just don't like the idea of like
falling out the [__] sky and like
knowing that you're gonna [__] die
and you don't really fall out of the sky
though
it's usually has lift
you know
they usually you know what I mean yeah
you know what I usually make it down to
the to the ground and try to land it and
then it descend again you know there's
always usually that's what I mean but I
don't I don't like that either yeah
that's usually how it goes I mean yeah I
feel like I don't know what the exact
percentage is but the vast majority of
crashes happen either on takeoff or
landing and actually we got uh one of
each flight 191 happened on takeoff and
uh Flight 401 happened when they were
Landing there was a couple of them where
you know part of the plane disintegrated
in flight and the people are getting
sucked out
and some of them were in their seat
belts and riding in the whole way
without a roof on the top of the plane
that the section that they were in
that'd have been Wild
there's a photograph that really would
never there's a photograph of that plane
coming in and [__] part of the roof's
gone you can see the dab seats and
people holding onto the seats and
they're in the seat but there's no wall
or [__] no side to the fuselage and
no top just the bottom and then you see
the seats in there it's probably for
about you could probably see about
five or six rows
five or six rows that's what I mean well
it kind of like reminds me of um what
the [__] was the
it made a big impression but it was a
few years ago it was a trailer for a
movie or maybe it was that TV show Lost
I can't remember but they had like the
and they had that like at the beginning
like in the trailer
where they showed like the the tail of
the plane like coming off and people
getting sucked out like in the seats and
stuff and it's like that I can't even
[__] watch that it just it makes me
like want to throw up
they had another one that was like that
where a piece of fuselage [__]
started tearing apart and it sucked uh
foreign
stewardess out
and she felt they were like 30 000 feet
you know yeah I remember that story and
she lived yeah she did she lived she she
fell the whole way down and then lived
she hit a hit the in she just had the
Speed was just right and she hit the
back side of the hill and slowed her
down
and um it was uh
you know it was like Clover and grass
and the it was wet she was she was
busted up but she she uh she lived can
you [__] imagine I would just like
you wouldn't be able to believe it
you're like on the [__] ground all of
a sudden I think terminal velocity is I
think it's about 120 130 miles an hour I
think that's what it is again yes but
she had forward
forward
motion from falling out of the plane
maybe that got bled off because the
planes probably going close to what 600
miles an hour
500 something like that yeah
so it would take a while for her to kind
of bleed that speed off but she'd still
be falling down
you know she
'd basically be hitting at at least 100
come on screaming her [__] head off
the whole way down I'll be spread out
trying to be as much like a flag
chipmunk as I could man on the way down
Trent it's like oh if only had arm flaps
yeah
I've seen videos of people I think it
was in India dude jumps maybe I forget
what country it was jumping out of a
burning building and uh he had a
mattress
yeah remember that yeah tried to land on
his own mattress it didn't work though
it turned upside down instantly and he
he let go of the mattress
well I mean it was a good thing I'll try
but you didn't realize it would do that
I mean you know he would have died if
he'd stayed in the building anyway I'd
strap myself to the mattress
well I don't know if you'd really have
time and you'd probably have time and
you'd probably be panicking yeah like I
would imagine you'd probably still hit
first though it turned upside down
probably like that man toast always hits
the floor and buttered side down yeah
it's that kind of [__] rule you know
what I mean grabbing sheets and holding
the corners together and making a
parachute
that's another thing I don't love
[__] tall buildings either I don't
really want to like live in a tall
building or like work in a tall building
or anything over the third [__] floor
yeah no thanks no thanks [__] all that
because then if you you know there's a
fire what I'm not jumping out [__] that
[__] [__] that [__] I don't like heights
I just do not
um yeah they're talking about uh there
was a movie about the the flight 401
thing called the classic place 401. I
remember hearing about that I don't
think I saw it though I remember well
I'm gonna say I remember when it
happened but I remember hearing about it
so because you know this back in the 70s
and I was a little kid but you know it
was pretty because I was just like ooh
the Everglades and like I said anytime
it's like a plane crash I'm gonna hear
about it because I'm there I find them
horrifying
uh Larry creature said what about a
mattress either side of you strapped
around easy win there you go a sandwich
I did actually that actually might be
better yeah that'd probably be better
yeah oh my God if you were strapped up
in there
yeah that's actually a good idea if you
can get your hands on like two
mattresses and have time to
I've come off my bike in about 70. uh
you didn't have far to fall
so I can't imagine actually hitting
straight into something at 130. you'd
Splat like a bug that's what I mean
because you just coming off your
motorcycle at that like you were still
you were pretty busted up and you had
all like armor and helmets and
everything on yeah I got up and first
thing I just run towards the bike
oh and how bad did I [__] it up at all
and sliders on my bike yeah I was more
worried about that and then of course
you were an hour later I couldn't
[__] walk and I'm getting [__] it
in I fell asleep and Jenny tries to
[__] wake me up uh couldn't even move
she didn't feed me she had to feed could
take my clothes off
I put a Big Mac like on his chest and
like push it toward his mouth yeah
and just I was rock hard from just being
it was like you've been beaten by a
baseball bat so sore was just everything
would just rock hard couldn't move
[__] limp into the bathroom I was
pissing blood yeah
but I didn't say anything it stopped
after a while so you know yeah you told
me after yeah it was all right because I
would have made you go to the hospital
yeah I was looking for [__] like that
but it was just because I got hit bad on
the side it was like I think it was just
because remember I got hit the kidney
yeah
most of my body was just bruises I mean
I remember you called me at work and
told me and I was like well I'll come
home and you're no no no I'm fine and
then I got home and I'm like you're
[__] not fine you were like laying on
the bed going
yeah and you couldn't move yeah it was
uh it's because I hit a cat
yeah yeah it was an accident
just going a cat jumped right in front
of the bike I couldn't stop in time and
I saw the looked down and saw the
because it wasn't in the road and then
you hit it that's not the way it is
you're going there's nothing in front of
you and down below a sarcat jump right
into the wheel and I looked down
and saw him in slow motion with his
claws out and everything like he was
trying to catch the front tire Jesus
Christ is this black cat poor kid as
soon as I saw that I locked the front
wheel up he got caught up underneath
there somehow the front end slid up
underneath me
yikes and then I was next thing I know I
was on my back back and I was on my back
sliding at about 70 and the bike was
right next to me sliding right along we
were like hey bike what's going on and
then I'm starting to slow down the bike
kept going
and I wrote it back
with busted controls on the left side
yeah so I couldn't change gears I mean
yeah I mean considering the bike uh
didn't really get I mean it got damaged
but not that day like I said it was
still mostly sliders and bumpers that I
had on it goddamn layering creature
which asked which bike it was it's a
Buell XB12R yeah it's the one you still
have yeah you fixed it but yeah it was I
was amazed that it wasn't more busted up
yeah actually it was the right side
wasn't no no it was the left side
because the shifter was busted I don't
remember yeah shift was busted in the in
the right clip-on was [__] bent in
like that
but I was able to limp the bike back and
I was like in
fourth gear when it happened so I had to
ride it back and forth gear I couldn't
change the gears because the shift lever
was gone
yep that was a special time
[Laughter]
I always keep worrying like every time
because he still goes out on that bike a
couple once or twice a week
I'm always trying to worry that he's
gonna call me there's always something
out of your control it's never something
how does that make it any better that
doesn't make it any better
you know what I mean yeah these people
likers are thinking the same thing in
the plane crash I'm like that doesn't
make any better they're still dead I'm
all right that's [__] up all right
that [__] happens
longer now than I was then
I'm just [__] loaded up with
anti-inflammatories too
all the [__] that I'm on you just can't
be you can't there's no swelling you
know
so Tom Sykes is asking what's your
opinion on electric motorcycles oh
they're good real good but batteries
really aren't ready yet
they're heavy
um there's a lot of speed a lot of power
I mean electric electric stuff is really
where it's at once you can get the
batteries right a battery has to be
light and has to be able to store a lot
of energy so you can have decent range
and you have to have really quick
recharge
uh you know what I mean so you're not
sitting there for two hours recharging
this [__] thing or four hours
recharging and only getting 100 mile
range that that's stupid
but
when it comes to just electric motors
they'll beat internal combustion all the
time
but you know they're trying look
that electric motor and the batteries
that they're using will not replace
internal combustion engines in
performance utility and cheapness not
for another 100 years this whole
electric car thing it's a scam
that's not ready
the batteries that can do it are
extremely caustic
and and expensive and dangerous they can
catch on fire there's all kinds of acids
and [__] in them they're not giving
those out to the public the ones they're
using are lithium and there's a limited
amount of lithium
uh
combustion is going to be where it's at
until you can figure out how to make
Fusion Energy
you can have an onboard Fusion reactor
to run your electric system that's when
you have electric
hell yeah and you it is possible we just
don't have the technology that's 100
years away you want a fusion reaction
about the size of a [__] toaster
that's what you want
and it just [__]
boils water that's all it does and the
steam power runs the damage it runs a
damn electric generator
and then it runs directly to a wheel and
a front wheel and a back wheel a motor
in each Hub so you have two wheel drive
on a motorcycle it would be unbeatable
and it's all torque
but the batteries aren't going to cut it
Zach says uh Anna De armas is officially
an Oscar nominee for that Marilyn Monroe
movie she did I still haven't seen that
I know that you um you know recommended
it and actually it looks really good but
I still and I love honor to armas but
it's like you know we'll get around to
seeing it one of these days you know who
that is right yeah from uh Blade Runner
yeah yeah there you go she's cute she is
cute as hell she was also in uh she was
no time to die she was also in um she
was in knives out too wouldn't she yeah
she was awesome at knives out that's the
ultimate Latin girl
I do want to see that Marilyn Monroe
movie though yeah still I kind of forgot
about it but yeah now that you reminded
me
I'll go watch it all right so uh so
let's talk about some [__] plane
crashes oh this is gonna cause me a
great deal of anxiety like even just
like I said even doing all the research
for this is like stressing me out
because this is one of just literally
like my worst nightmare
so uh so yeah let's talk about flight
191.
that's first story
so this happened Friday May 25th 1979.
this was actually the start of Memorial
Day weekend that year
so on this particular day uh what was I
believe at the time of the worst airline
disaster in American history I think
it's been superseded since then but uh
at the time it was the worst one uh
killed 271 people passengers and crew so
the flight was actually going from
Chicago it took off from O'Hare airport
to Los Angeles uh but it never actually
left Chicago as we'll see
so as I mentioned this is the start of
the Memorial Day Weekend uh the plane I
believe was full
because it was a holiday weekend and
actually there was also
um there was a big like booksellers
Association conference like out in La so
there was like a lot of literate like
authors book editors like stuff like
that like a bunch of them were on the
plane too because they were going out to
the same thing
so the plane that they got on was a
McDonald Douglas DC-10
now they got on it just before 3 P.M
we'll talk about the DC town a little
bit later because this
this crash as well as some other ones uh
probably contributed to
um the DC-10 not having a great
reputation
uh now this particular plane uh had a
flown flown I believe for 20 000 hours
and was totally fine
uh also the crew were all very very
experienced the captain was named Walter
Lux uh he had actually been flying DC
TENS for 10 years like since they had
first started doing them uh your first
officer was named James Dillard and you
had a flight engineer named Alfred
udovic uh so all of them they had
basically like 25 000 flight hours
between them so these are no noobs
nothing like that
so 2 59 p.m uh the plane is cleared to
start its taxi down the runway
so it starts down the runway as usual
and then it's okay everything's going
just fine there's nothing no no
indication that anything is amiss
it gets about 6 000 feet down the runway
like the nose is not even like you know
up yet or anything like that
now at this point like somebody in the
tower
saw parts of what they call the port
engine pylon like coming away from the
aircraft and then saw like some kind of
like white smoke or white Vapor like
coming from there
probably Fuel and then no we'll I'll get
into what it was
now um a couple of seconds after that
like just as soon as like the person
calls like what you know what's that all
about because it was like way down there
um and then the the planes started
liftoff
now side note here's one thing I think
this was the most alarming fact that I
learned while I was doing the research
for this I didn't know this previously
but when the plane is taxiing down the
runway
before it's taken off even like while
the all the wheels are still on the
ground there is apparently a a speed
that it gets to after which it has to
take off you know what I mean like it
can't you can't just be like oh never
mind and like slow it back down you know
what I mean you can't do like you have
to take off and even if they are like oh
[__] like some critical thing is wrong
they have to take off and then sort it
out like once they get up which I was
like well that's horrifying I didn't
know that well there's probably not not
enough room up in front that's what I'm
saying so I so like a point of no return
right so I I kind of didn't realize they
said yeah once it gets to a certain
point you have to take off like even if
you know that there's something to
matter yeah like you can't just like
stop and be like never mind do-over you
know what I mean and I was like well
yeah you wouldn't stop in time you'd run
off the Runway right exactly
yeah so
it's uh that was not a fun fact that I
learned but yeah
oh I'm not sure they have breaks
because I think I think most of those
airliners Break by reversing their
engine thrust
with uh some yeah there may be brakes on
the wheels but I don't I think they
might use the jet engines to slow it
down probably there's probably breaks on
the wheels are probably not strong
enough to stop that thing
I would imagine see I always kind of
wondered about that like I'm not like
you can just like slam on the brakes
yeah just slide right it would just
slide I'm not really sure how it works
and honestly now that I've learned that
fact I'm really not sure that I want to
know there might be some breaks for when
it's taxiing around at low speed but I
think they mostly just pull that thing
around on a little tractor
in that little tractor that pulls the
plane around yeah yeah yeah
Tom Sykes says the plane crash scene
from The Mummy and World War Z were
horrifying on screen yeah I remember
those ugh like I said I have a hard time
like watching that [__] even in a movie
and I know it's fake I'm just like yeah
I don't like that
um but yeah so as this particular plane
took off
like the nose went up
and while it was taking off the entire
engine one of the entire engines and the
pylon
came off the plane like tore off the
plane flipped up and went over the wing
you can see there's animations of it
like all over the place like I said
which is like [__] horrifying to
watch it went up yeah it went up and
over and crashed down into the runway
like behind the plane I wonder why it
went up and didn't go down and um
um I'm not real sure actually well I
guess because the plane was going
forward so quickly and it was kind of
going up in the air like a little bit
like its nose was kind of up like I said
you if you if you search it like you can
see like animations where they recreated
it like um inside that engine is a big
rotating turbine blade well it's it's
like a it's like a shaft with a bunch of
turbines a bunch of fan blades getting
smaller as they go and there's fuel
injectors in there pump and it's like a
it the way the jet engine works it's a
trip it's like a propeller in the front
a propeller in the back and you're
making it making an explosion or burning
fuel in the middle which pushes the dam
blades in the back which push the blades
in the front which sucks more fuel and
some when they first kind of tried to
figure out a j engine of course it
didn't work people said no that's that's
impossible that's like a perpetual
motion machine
but if you have the mathematics right it
does work
it's basically kind of like a
Turbocharger but you're burning fuel
inside the turbocharger so it's a lot
like that
I think that's where they got the idea
from putting a turbocharger on a World
War one plane they said you know what we
could probably get rid of the motor and
just burn fuel in that and it would it
would be it just you know it would suck
air in the front and blow [__] fire
out the back
and with fuel itself
it's a cool idea but it took a long time
to figure it out so maybe when the when
it when the engine broke off the pylon
because it's got a big rotating mass in
there maybe it went crazy and flipped
went forward and flipped over the wing
because this gyroscopic effects yeah
but I've seen I've seen the re the
recreation that they did it makes sense
that it comes off the plane and it goes
over the wing yeah it doesn't look weird
like when you see it okay like it looks
pretty that didn't make any sense you
think it would just fall away from there
that's not what it did okay like I said
I've seen the the the recreation and
it's all right I'd have to see it so I
know what you're talking about it was
like that
um Thomas Sykes said just recently some
female airport worker got sucked into
the plane's engine now that's terrifying
to say yeah I can't imagine I mean at
least for that person to be quick but
it's like I don't really like to have to
be
the person like seeing that either like
that would be really horrible
and that and it happens too like because
um
planes get that you know like birds will
fly like get sucked into the engine too
bird strike things one of those aircraft
carrier Crews got sucked into a damn
intake of a jet yeah they got it on
video he lived though
it took him it sucked him into the
intake but there's something there to
stop him from going all the way in just
pulled yeah you think there'd be like
some kind of safety yeah you know what I
mean because otherwise everybody that
walked by oh [__] yeah the engine flamed
out [__] shot it's like choppy to
people shot a bunch of fire and smoke
out the back of it and it kind of
stalled
him out how bad was he didn't kill him
well that's not what I had I think if
I'm bad I don't think it didn't it
didn't end his service you know what I
mean he was probably okay in a couple
days
yeah well he had a good story to tell he
could get probably free drinks on that
for the rest of his life oh he got
sucked into an engine [__] yeah tell
the tail they're running around and
getting the thing ready for a [__]
flight on on a carrier deck and the guy
[__]
spoiled up the engine whoa suck that guy
right in there you can see it it's it's
going to be on I've seen videos if that
happened to people you can see it on
YouTube but yeah yikes guys sucked into
an engine
and then the [__] engine looks look
like it flamed out Shadow about a fire
out of the back of it and bunch of black
smoke and it looked like it stalled
like I said I said I don't think I've
seen that one but I have seen videos of
that happening to people and it's just
like well does he block the air intake
yeah he blocked all the air you know and
without air it can't run
yeah that's pretty scary yeah
Zach says the only time I feel nervous
when flying is when I'm on those flimsy
feeling puddle jumper planes they have
going between neighboring states and
stuff I've only been on those kind of
planes
um probably once or twice when I was
flying from where was I flying from
Denver to Santa Fe and that's like a
little bitty plane like they do it every
and that was a new experience I was
flying with my dad and his friend who
was a doctor who owned this damn
he was teaching my dad to fly my dad was
getting his buyers license ended flying
into Cessna
and you think that puddle jumper shit's
[__] freaky flying one of those
Cessna it's like flying in a cheap VW
Bug the whole thing [__] flexes and
battles and you're like looking and it's
it's very everything's very lightweight
and we're up there doing stalls
practicing stalls my dad's making making
stalls happening and then getting out of
the stall it was like being in a roller
coaster
this [__] is wild did you have did they
have bark bags no I liked it
yeah but I'm saying of people that have
like motion sickness no this dude's
playing it's like it's like it's like
being in a guy's car you know
cars can't fall out of the sky
generally
you know just saying no bar bags you
know I was just asking yeah no
no just asking they were in there
laughing and joking around you just
gotta puke in your shirt I guess
you don't get sick like that
I didn't well it's like some people
probably do I've never seen it I've
never seen that happen to anybody I've
never seen anybody throw up in a bag and
I've never even seen an air sickness bag
I was a little kid that had them but I
haven't seen one of those recently I've
never seen anybody using them like that
it's nowhere near what seat what
seasickness was I've been seeing yeah
seasickness is very different yeah
that's worse I will I will give you that
like that is actually going up and down
that was out in the Gulf I don't get
nauseated on airplanes or or in cars but
I know some people do it takes hours for
me to get seasick because it usually
because that usually has something to do
with your inner ear you know what I mean
like people that get motion sickness so
I don't usually I just I feel really
stressed out on planes but I don't get
like a no but I have seen people throw
up like when there's like turbulence and
stuff I have seen people using those
barf bags
that was just like a few years ago
so
um so yeah so the whole [__] engine
comes off and I guess like the tower saw
it and they obviously they call the
plane and they're like uh you know on
the radio and they're like um hey do you
guys want to come back you look like
you're having kind of a problem there uh
what Runway do you want like if you want
to come back
uh the plane the pilot or nobody nobody
replied like on the radio and the plane
started to go up like it normally would
the only thing that was unusual at first
was the left wing like dipped for a
second
and then it straightened back out again
and then started climbing just like it
normally would if it was taking off now
it did that for about 10 seconds
um and then when it was about 300 feet
off the ground
the plane started to bank to the left
like first very very slightly and then
very very sharply
now at that point the nose of the plane
uh dip down and the airplane started to
go back down toward the ground
um and basically the wings went vertical
and then like that and then it just
[__] hit the ground
uh the whole thing took about 31 seconds
like from what it took off uh and here
was the horrifying thing
so this particular airline did what I
say it's American Airlines right yeah
American Airlines had just installed
what they thought would be a fun thing
for the passengers they put like um you
know how they had like the little uh you
know movies that you could watch like in
the 70s I think it was kind of up here
in the ceiling like where you could
watch little movies well they had that
but they had instead of a movie they
were showing you like what the pilot
sees like when he's taking off so you
could see like the you know you could
see like the runway rushing and stuff
like that so it's like when the sh the
[__] was happening like when the plane
went up and then went like that and then
like went back down toward the [__]
ground everybody in the back of the
plane was watching it on the [__]
screen and could see because I'm like oh
boy isn't that fun not surprisingly not
too long after this they're like maybe
that's not such a good idea because even
before like when they said oh they
thought it would be a fun thing I'm like
why would that be a fun I want to
[__] see that Jesus Christ I want to
pretend I'm on a bus or I'm just like on
the ground I didn't want to know that
I'm in the [__] sky so it's like much
less wanting to see what the pilot sees
[__] that [__] so I could have told him
that before they even spent all the
money to install the technology
but yeah so that's the thing and like I
said 31 seconds it doesn't sound like a
really long time but when all of the
horrified people are in the plane and
the plane is going like that
and then you know very quickly like
going back toward the ground I'm sure it
probably felt like a [__] eternity
there's a package at the door oh because
oh okay yeah because they were all uh
very aware of what was going on which
that's the worst like I said it probably
just felt like forever even though it
was 31 seconds this is like stressing me
out can you tell just like here just
just talking about it it's stressed me
out and I've been like watching and like
I've been reading about this all day and
like watching documentaries about this
all day and it's like starts me out
so so yeah so the wing tip on the left
side of the plane uh you know basically
hit the ground first and then it just
went into there was a massive massive
explosion
um and basically the fireball went about
a half a mile
and went into there was this like
abandoned hanger
which was um where the old airport was
like it was called Ravenswood Airport
and there was also like a mobile home
park like right near the airport and the
plane basically went kind of like in
that direction like it actually wiped
out some of the trailers it didn't kill
anybody in the trailer park
um I think it [__] up uh five of the
mobile homes maybe it was more than that
but um two people on the ground however
were killed not in the trailer park but
I think they worked in a garage either
like just off-site or on site of the
airport like because when the plane hit
the ground like it mostly hit a field
but it hit like a bunch of like houses
and stuff
um so everybody that was on the plane
271 people all passengers All crew
killed instantly
and they said that when they went to
uh
clean it all up or see what it's like
they said it was just like
there was barely there was not really
like a lot left of the plane
um and they said they you'd go there and
you could just smell
burning flesh and they said it was just
like
blackened torsos and [__] like that just
like it was like it was horrible and I
was watching like another documentary
about it earlier I can't remember it was
like a British one and the [__] up
thing about it is that because they were
kind of like talking about a few people
that have been on the plane because they
talked like to the survivors you know
the or the people's families and stuff
and the one guy he had just had like he
watches his girlfriend got on the plane
and then he went and watched the plane
he's like oh I'm gonna go outside and
watch the plane take off and see her go
off to Los Angeles and he saw the
[__] plane crash
he's like uh yeah so he watched his
[__] girlfriend die like on the [__]
I'm just like oh my God I can't [__]
imagine so they were like talking I mean
it's been many years but he still looked
pretty like [__] up about it which
yeah well it wasn't personalized really
he didn't see her dying he just saw the
plane crash right but it's like you know
that yeah she was annihilated instantly
she's just vaporized that's [__] up
yeah but you know it happens well yeah
but like I said that doesn't make it no
okay like that doesn't make anybody feel
any better about it nothing's okay
so yeah
so all these people got killed like I
said two people on the ground also
killed and it [__] up a bunch of
people's houses because there was like a
trailer park there where it landed
yeah and they knocked out the trailer
park well some of it I think it was like
five or six trailers got knocked out I
don't think anything no uh no I don't
think anybody was home they got a check
they got a paycheck but I mean I would
hope so yeah the airline Insurance
[__] Jesus Christ
that's that's [__] horrifying yeah
somebody's asking if my dad was in the
Air Force or something he said no
foreign
s was a doctor who owned his own
airplane it was a Cessna
but he had a and a heart attack a couple
of years before so he was afraid to fly
it by himself
so he took my dad with him my dad wanted
to get his pilot's license
so he was training my dad on how to fly
the airplane even he would even land it
and my dad was studying up to get his
little uh passenger or Pilot slices
but he would land it plain and fly it
and uh because the guy was afraid he'd
have a heart attack while he was flying
he wanted somebody with him that could
land the plane
but he never my dad never did actually
take the test though he lost interest he
learned how to fly it and he goes [__] I
don't have an airplane so why do I need
the why do I need the license
you know
I think it was like a several thousand
dollars to take the test I think two
that's the yeah probably that's part of
it's expensive yeah
and uh it was like a long process to
take the test and he's like why am I
actually taking this test I'm flying an
airplane already and how to do it you
know and I don't own my own airplane so
why should I really get the test I have
the skill if I if I get an airplane then
I'll [__] take the test you know well
that makes sense yeah yeah what are you
gonna do if like you pay for it now I
don't know you can't like I can't use it
yeah you can't use it because you don't
have an airplane but he's already flying
an airplane every time his friend goes
up yeah so you know Larry said he didn't
need an airplane
yeah that's it my dad playing around you
know really really what he wanted as an
ultralight
you don't need to papaya sizes for that
but he knew that if you got that ultra
light he'd be dead
because those dudes [__] crash they
got a high mortality rate they do yeah
yeah it's probably better now but I mean
well yeah most things are better now but
a lot of people had to die for like
improve [__] you know what I mean uh
yeah Larry said also having folks been
sucked out of the play in midair in
their seat and survived a few have a few
have
um I don't know of any cases
particularly but I do remember somewhere
where that's happened and they lived
well like I said that one um flight
attendant she got sucked out of the
plane and she lived but she wasn't in a
seat though she just got sucked out
and she lived and she fell all that way
she didn't have anything I thought her
fall got broken by some trees or some
[__] though
didn't it did she which one the one that
you were talking about earlier
the woman that fell out no that's two
different cases oh okay yeah I remember
the girl that fell into the tree she
lived but broke her legs all up they
they ended up I think she crawled her
way to a road and somebody drove by and
they found her I think that's how she
stayed the other one hit the bat she hit
a hill at the right angle
and hit the downward slope it slowed her
down that's how I remember that one
yeah you know what I mean now we're
going to do a show about people that
fell out yeah
we're talking about a pretty steep hill
yeah and if you hit that steep slope it
will slow you down
but you have Forward Motion too you're
not falling straight down
so it was just
a chance pure chance
yeah that was probably never happened it
would never happen more than once she
passed over the tip of a hill
at the right speed to line up with the
[__] slope and hit it and just load
it slowed her down enough to where she
got broken bones but she lived
now if you had one of them squirrel
suits you could make that happen
see maybe next time I have to fly I'll
get one of those yeah
I watch those dudes do that squirrel
shoot suit [__] I was like man I could
do that
you know I think I'd like that
but there's no room for error you've got
to get that right your first your first
attempt
you know what I mean but but they were
I've seen those guys jump off of [__]
mountains and go down through canyons
and do stuff and I was like yeah I can
see and they're doing I could see their
helmet cam and I was like yeah it's kind
of like a motorcycle going fast but at a
at a slope you know I said I could do
that
but I couldn't tell you I see how they
were controlling it you know
there's a lot of body English and stuff
it's like I could do that
but um and they landed basically that's
a trip huh
they don't land it like an airplane I
guess they they fold up at the end I
guess I don't remember how they landed
it I don't remember either I'm gonna be
showing it's a squirrel suit but they
were
yeah you could make a connection with a
slope
and slow yourself down in a controlled
Crash Landing in a squirrel suit like I
said maybe I will just like wear a pair
of shoes next time I have to like yeah
parachute be safe next next yeah I mean
next time that I have to fly in a plane
I'll just be like well I'm bringing a
parachute because squirrel shoots
lighter though
I know but and what you could do is you
could go on a ninja Commando mission and
reach down and then
you can have that [__] like a superhero
and jump off a building and [__]
control it and Boogie your way down and
try to find an object to hit to slow
yourself down to take some of your speed
away
yeah well you guys have fun doing it
yeah I'm not doing that [__] you got to
bleed off some speed
I'm not doing that [__] land on the roof
of a car and bust all the windows out
[Laughter]
all right so uh so yeah so obviously
um a wreck of this magnitude
is going to get people's attention so
this was obviously a Countrywide story
and people started wondering about the
DC-10 because there had been a couple of
other kind of major crashes uh also of
dc-10s like in the past few years and
people were starting to think you know
what the [__] are they not safe or
what's the deal and also people were
wondering they're like look
um yeah you lost an engine and that's
bad like when the engine flew off but
technically uh it should have been able
to fly without that you know what I mean
because planes have more than one engine
and they're designed to fly basically on
only one so you can lose I mean your
real big jumbo Jets I think they have
four engines and they're and if you lose
three engines it can still fly yeah so
they didn't really know they said really
um even though this lost an entire
engine like as in it popped off the
plane
um it should have still been able to fly
so they couldn't like figure out what
the problem was
so uh the NTSB did a really really long
investigation of this and actually
there's a really good there's actually
two really good like British
documentaries they're different
um about how they figured out what had
happened with this [__] because it took
them a while
but it's actually like really
interesting so what ended up happening
was that there was an engine pylon
because like you have the big you have
the big engine right there like on the
underside of the wing and then there's a
pylon there's like a thing that I can't
let everybody describe the shape of it
but it almost kind of looks like a
bracket type thing that like holds it
onto the wing right
now what ended up happening was that
about I think it was eight weeks prior
to the crash this particular plane had
been uh had some maintenance at the
American Airlines facility in Tulsa
Oklahoma
now the engine had just needed routine
maintenance like you do
and something that they discovered uh
during this investigation was that
American Airlines as well as some other
airlines as well had been cutting
Corners a little bit
so the thing about it is that when you
were doing maintenance on the engine
um you're supposed to
um kind of like take the whole assembly
apart and it was like a whole I don't
remember how many bolts it was but it
was like some ridiculous amount of bolts
that you better take out and it took
like forever you know what I mean
so a lot of airlines including American
Airlines had taken to removing the
entire engine and pylon as a single unit
they were basically taking the whole
thing off the wing in one piece yeah
like with three or four bolts instead of
disassembling the whole thing like you
were supposed to do like the
manufacturer recommended because they
said it saved something like 200 man
hours yeah like just taking it so what
they would do is they would like back a
forklift underneath where the engine was
and just had like the forklifts and they
would take the whole thing off and like
pull it out and like work on it and then
put it back on
um and they weren't supposed to be doing
that but nobody knew it because you know
they were just trying to like save money
save time that seems to make sense I
mean kind of things that you you you
normally would do right but that's like
I said the manufacturer very clearly
said in the manual you have to take the
whole thing off like when you're doing
this I promise you give a reason why
either because the mechanics on the
ground same thing in the military
mechanics on the ground
read those re read [__] Factory [__]
and goes what the [__] are they talking
about there's a better way to do that
you know that's what happened there may
have been a reason
why don't just take the don't take the
whole [__] pile under but they should
have stated it why because you know how
mechanics are
they're gonna go that's [__] you
know just do it this way
well in this case it got almost 300
people killed so good job well in fact
we should have said why don't do that
well how about you just follow
instructions no it doesn't work does not
work with mechanics dudes do not follow
instructions nope that's their problem
because mechanics a mechanic that knows
that thing inside and out maybe he
hasn't done all the [__] stress
testing or anything but mechanic that
knows the whole system inside and out is
used to getting instructions from
factories that are full of [__] we're
just they're just used to it you know
I've built a lot of engines and [__]
they'll just tell you like no
but
when it's something real important
usually has to do with lawsuits but you
if it's something real important they'll
tell you why not to do something do not
do this because what could happen is
pressure could go up and you can blow
your [__] up
and then you go oh yeah okay yeah don't
do that
we'll see okay so the work around that
they had done on their of their own
volition like without permission was
like I said they were back in a forklift
up like and they were lowering the um
the engine onto it now basically the
problem was you had to get the engine
assembly like exactly straight like on
this [__] portlet forklift while it
was being taken off and that was a
really really difficult thing to be able
to do because the person driving the
forklift couldn't really see what they
were doing and it's like there was
somebody back here kind of looking at it
it was just like very
cobbled together and obviously it wasn't
really working all that well
because if it was just like a little bit
off when they were taking it off or
putting it back on then there would be
um a crack in the pylon that you
wouldn't necessarily be able to see
so basically um after this particular
accident and they figured out what it
was they went and looked at a bunch of
other dc-10s not just American Airlines
but a bunch of other ones and they
figured out that like a lot of other
airlines had been cutting Corners like
that and doing this procedure in this
particular way and a lot of those pylons
had [__] cracks in them uh that's the
pylon that holds the engine onto the
wing okay that's why that's why they
don't want you to do that because it
wears out the pylon yes if there's a
little crack in it they're like you know
you can fly it a bunch of times but
every time you fly it the crack might
get a little bit bigger and a little bit
bigger torque and it dispatch and
they're like there and it wears out and
they go look man I would charge it to
spec and it's not right it's a little
loose so they tighten it up a little bit
more each time and over time it starts
cracking [__] in the next minute but you
see the thing is them [__] should
have said that in the manual because
it's just human nature they're gonna
like well this is shorter why don't we
just take the pylon off
yeah I know I understand what they were
thinking that's why hey man when I was a
fleet mechanic okay [__] for uh
[__] State Police at a state police
level
for a while
if a [__] car came in and it [__]
had a rod knocking We're Not Gonna
rebuild that engine we're just gonna
pull that engine and put throw another
engine in it now take that engine put it
on a stand like to get that car back out
on the street now the blown engine we'll
put that on a stand and rebuild it later
on and use that as a replace as a spare
replacement engine for another car that
comes in don't put the same engine back
in that car it takes too long
uh you know what I mean well sometimes
so you're always easier to just start
over yeah so we always have like a
rebuilt ready to go engines ready on
stands you know car comes in with a
[__] up engine or just something like
that engine doesn't sound right just
pull that engine
put the other engine in it get it out
that's like [__] three hours of work
the rebuild takes longer you know and
you gotta Source parts so well see I've
always found and I feel like this is
true in a lot of different fields not
just mechanics because I found it in my
own field as well of graphic design you
get some [__] from some someone else
that has made something in my case it's
usually like they've made like a file or
something you don't know what program
they use you know what version of that
they use you don't know what anything
they use so like you open it and it's a
[__] show
um so basically usually what I would do
it's much much quicker to just remake
the whole thing from scratch rather than
try to figure out what the [__] they did
to it
you know what I mean because there's
always something wrong so that's kind of
the thing I feel like a lot of times
it's just easier to just be like [__] it
and just like start all over yeah I mean
you can tell difference between
accessories something that's bolted onto
an engine like you know like alternator
or [__] fuel engine or [__]
steering pumps you can
[__] AC compressor
you can identify that but if you look at
that motor and you go man there's
something wrong with it you can just
disconnect all that [__] pull the motor
put a different motor in it [__]
reconnect everything to it send it out
the door
whole thing three hours
good but there's four of us working
then you worry about that engine later
because that's going to take a long time
to rebuild that engine yeah you just get
to it when you get to get to it you know
what I mean yeah and you got four other
rebuilt ones sitting on stands ready to
go
you know what I mean so no rush
but yeah see the the problem with this
was that honestly
um the way that they were cutting
corners and like I said it wasn't just
American Airlines but it was pretty much
all the dc-10s because it was you know
this particular configuration that they
had and a lot of airlines had been using
this cost saving and labor-saving
measure for the air for the um engine
maintenance and because of that when
they went back and like looked at a
bunch of other dc-10s they found pretty
much the same problem they would like
they would go in there and see the pylon
there'd be a little crack so the thing
about it was that it could basically go
at any time yeah like you never knew
like it just happened to happen this one
time and they caught it they didn't
design them damn pylons robustly enough
to be [__] removed and [__]
or or to be to be detached and
reattached over and over again wore them
out
they had to they should have used a
different material should have been more
robust they should have had the damn
Russians build it whenever the Russians
built aircraft and built it like a
[__] tank
but you know they tried to make things
as light as possible with an American
aircraft all the aluminum and magnesium
and titanium and all that [__] but
everything's kind of fragile
so I see what they're doing but
big money you know it's cheaper to make
it out of something harder and [__]
steel you know
something real robust but like I said if
you watch one of these um documentaries
because like there are a couple good
ones that I watched earlier
um that were both British and they have
like really good animation like showing
you pretty much exactly what happened
because they did figure out like uh what
happened because the thing about it was
that they did even though the plane was
like exploded when it hit the ground and
there wasn't much of it left they did
actually find enough pieces of the pylon
to like kind of sort out what had
happened you know what I mean yeah and
then but I mean the horrifying thing was
that when they went and checked the
other [__] they're like oh my God like a
lot of other mechanics are doing the
same thing which means this could have
happened at any time it just so happened
that it happened on this day you're
doing the same thing we were doing
engine swapping and the thing about it
too was that
um they thought for a for a time they
were like well they weren't really sure
what ended up happening was I think that
the pilots weren't aware
because it should have been able to take
off anyway but I think they weren't
really aware of what was going on and
they kind of they didn't do anything
wrong they did everything by the book
but I believe that the plane had stalled
and they didn't realize that it had
stalled so they kind of did what they
thought was the right thing and then but
they didn't know it was stalled and so
that was the wrong thing so it ended up
kind of like going around and it crashed
but it wasn't like it wasn't pilot error
it wasn't nothing like that because they
determined that like they didn't do
anything wrong it was just kind of like
you know it [__] happens kind of thing
so um so yeah so after this plane
crashed into the [__] ground and the
scary thing there's actually if you
search it's probably like the first
photo that comes up uh crash of Flight
191.
um there were pictures somebody that was
at the airport like took a picture and
it was all over the [__] papers at
the time
um of the plane going like that just
like over the you know over the airport
buildings and you could see like a
little bit of white smoke like coming
out
of the side like where the engine was
and uh somebody also got pictures of the
uh ensuing explosion which was also
pretty [__] up
so after this crash probably not
surprisingly
there were a bunch of ghost stories that
came about uh in its wake no no drink
yeah
now according to the local police
people who um were driving through the
area started to report weird things like
around where the plane had crashed
they would call in and say that they saw
these really eerie like bobbing white
lights in the area like in this field
like where the plane had crashed and
them they weren't thinking it was ghosts
they thought that there's like some
like [__] people in there maybe like
it's weird I was like looking for
souvenirs from the crash or some creepy
[__] like that so they thought it was
people with flashlights like over there
so they called the cops about it it's
like hey you want to go check that out
but they said every time the cops went
to look and see like no one was ever
there and like they never found any
evidence that people had been at the
site you know what I mean even though
people kept calling and Reporting seeing
like all these weird lights and stuff
and then even weirder than that
uh the people that lived in the mobile
home park because remember I said like
the plane kind of crashed part way into
it I don't think it necessarily it
didn't crash into the mobile home park
but it the um the debris like flew
really far and some of it like hit some
of the trailers and stuff like that
so um so yeah so some of the people that
lived in this mobile home park they said
basically just like a few hours after
the plane crash
um some of the people who lived in the
trailer park started hearing like
somebody knocking on their doors and
windows
and then they would go and nobody was
there
a lot of them reported their dogs would
start barking at the field where the
plane had crashed with no explanation
they would just sit there and like bark
at the field all day and they didn't
know why
and this went on for a very long time
like several weeks several months like
after the crash okay so they're saying
that the ghosts of the people killed and
the [__] yeah crash are walking
around knocking on doors seeking help
see well that's kind of what yeah that's
kind of what they're reporting yeah in
America there is real
real yeah yeah
in the plane crash there are ghosts
knocking on your door
can you imagine like I would shave my
pants if like that happen if there was
like a plane crash like right outside
your door literally and then all of a
sudden like a few hours later Like
Somebody's knocking at your door or like
banging on your [__] window or some
[__] like that [__] now what are the
sources who are saying this is just well
this these reports are from the local
police because they said people started
like calling in weird so the local
police about it's like why like there's
[__] like not gonna well the
first thing that got reported too this
hold on there's something to this people
if it was like a third party who jumped
in years later saying yeah everybody
started getting ghosts knocking on their
door I wouldn't believe in it these are
the cops saying people are calling them
in evidently at the time evidently yeah
evidently that's from what I could
determine so it is this just a person
claiming that the cops
I mean we'll get into the whole like
secondhand thing like in the flight 401
case okay all right but this one it does
seem to be like most of the cops said
yeah like people were reporting like I
said you I you weren't in here but like
people's the first thing people started
reporting was people would drive by and
they said you know we're seeing these
bobbing white lights ever in the field
like we think there's people over there
with flashlights like looking for
souvenirs from the crash site and that's
kind of [__] up so you might want to
go check that out and like the cops
wanted to check it out and then it's
like there was nobody there
so that was one thing but then like all
of the mobile home people started
calling and be like hey there's like
people knocking out the door and there's
nobody there
um you know and [__] like that uh and
then they also started and apparently it
started like ramping up because then
they would start reporting like that
their doorknobs were like rattling
um [__] like that they heard like
footsteps like on their steps like
outside like coming up to their doors
and uh a couple of residents reported
and I'm just saying what they reported I
don't know if this is true or not but
they reported um and this more than one
person reported this that they had heard
knocking at their door and they opened
it and they said there was a guy
standing there and he looked really
worried and he would either say that he
had to get his luggage or he had to make
his connecting flight like he would say
that yeah like the guy was standing on
their porch and then he would like turn
around and then kind of like disappear
so a couple people reported that too
damn which is pretty creepy I mean if
that really happened you could see how
it happened because like I don't believe
in ghosts really but it's just kind of
like if any place was haunted it would
be this place because these people died
like
really quick so it's just kind of like
they wouldn't even probably know they
were dead you know what I'm saying I
believe in the possibility of ghosts
maybe not in the way people would think
of a ghost like a spirit walking around
but maybe like
more like Echoes of the past things that
were recorded in the area to make a
place bad and you might be able to pick
up on them
I mean
pops uh
uh he's got his own show
he was xsf guy who was placed in charge
of the unit that was run in Abu garib
prison after all that big Scandal went
down his unit took over that and he said
that that [__] prison was haunted he
saw not just him but a bunch of other
people saw all kinds of [__] in hat in
Abu garib voices
weird bluish kind of glowing lights and
in the distance
voices coming down corridors of the
prison that had been walled off
and uh
most people will never know what Saddam
was doing to people in there man that
was a [__] bad place that was like on
par with like Auschwitz you know
torturing people that making people kill
themselves to escape torture
bad place real bad the whole place is
just streaming with bones
you dig around that area there'd be
human bones where they would burying
people out in the yards
so now I there are bad places
you might see some things
now whether whether or not that ghost or
that Spirit or soul of that person is
actually trapped there
I don't know it might be more like that
person's suffering kind of recorded in
into the damn fabric of the area and if
you're kind of attuned to it or let's
say you might have some psychic Talent
or your instinct or something you might
be able to access that this is a bad
place that bad things happened here you
know I mean I kind of feel like that's
why I'm not saying I necessarily believe
all the people that said that they saw
you know people like because there was
more which I'll get to in a minute but
you know if that they opened their door
and saw a guy saying I need to get my
luggage or whatever and then he
disappeared I mean like I said I don't
really believe in ghosts but if ghosts
exist I think it's more like like you
said like a psychic recording type of
situation so to me that would make more
sense because this was a very traumatic
very quick event
um and probably it left an impression
yeah you know what I mean of some kind
and maybe people could pick up on that
so you know I don't know if that's true
I'm just saying that sounds more likely
than yeah we're animals we have a lot of
instincts and we have a Quantum
Consciousness and uh animals do weird
things also you know they can tell what
direction it is they get bad feelings
about stuff and people who are more
attuned I think to the animal existence
of the fight for the fight for life for
survival between life and death they
tend to have feelings that come true you
know and they see things and detect
things
that the average person wouldn't because
they're just you know working behind a
laptop which that's a different kind of
work but it's not an animal type job you
know people say well that's just
Instinct but what is Instinct you know
there's a lot of things about the mind
and the unconscious that we don't
understand yet and what Consciousness is
but uh his name is Terence pops he's got
his own show I think it's called
redonculus and you can look on YouTube
and on bit shoot he's on there too I
think he might have been kicked no he's
not kicked off YouTube he's still on
there he's an X SF guy did like [__]
30 years
in a bunch of different kind of units
and uh he's got a bunch of ghost shows
about Abu garib prison and uh I've heard
his stories man I [__] believe him I
believe him
if if a place is going to be bad it's
going to be a place like that other
people that I've heard interviews when
they went to go see Auschwitz and some
of these death camps from World War II
they said it's got an eerie [__]
ominous feel I can imagine imagine all
those people just
murdered in on it at a damn industrial
scale you know there's going to be
that's going to be a bad place you know
they're just
I don't know that place is going to be
creepy
I'd be curious though because I'm a
skeptical person
um as far as like I know a lot of
horrible [__] happened there I'm talking
about in regards to hauntings
it would be interesting if you took
somebody there and this might be
impossible and they don't know what it
is yeah like if you just took somebody
there and you took them to a bunch of
other different control places and see
if they felt any different at that place
like somebody that didn't know what had
happened there yeah but I'd like to take
a a wide spectrum of people but that's
what I mean well that's what you would
usually do like by themselves each time
right yeah
because you would need a control group
and you would need somebody that didn't
know because if you know what happened
there I mean obviously pretty much
everybody on [__] Earth knows what
happened there so it's just kind of like
you're primed to be creeped out by that
because it's horrible I got a feeling
that more Primal people
would feel it I think more sophisticated
people wouldn't
animals would probably feel in children
would probably feel it
you know because I remember when I was
at the chat when I was a kid I had those
feelings they're a lot stronger and they
turned out to be true you know kids have
real good feelings and instincts because
that's all you're working on you don't
have experience to work on
you know you defend yourself from
[__] World Views but the thing about
it is that instincts can be wrong too
and I think and I think that sometimes
that people also have a tendency to
forget like all the times they had an
instinct of something that didn't amount
to anything you only remember the times
that it did amount to something I've
read a lot of stuff on this I'm just
saying yeah instincts can be wrong but
over time they tend to be right no I
didn't say that I'm just saying that you
have to like take it if you get a bad
feeling about some dude
trust your feelings okay well because
it's better to do it and like be wrong
right than just be like oh it's nothing
and then that dude ends up being Ted
Bundy a lot of those victims that
survive serial killers said I had a bad
feeling about that guy but I didn't want
to seem like I was you know being unfair
to him towards him so I let him in the
car no no
you had a bad feeling about that dude
because you were right
well the thing about it is that and
maybe this is changing nowadays but um
in general like women are usually like
socialized to be you don't want to be
rude right you don't want to be a [__]
[__] all that you don't want to be yeah
um and I kind of feel like you should
not absolutely not be afraid if you have
a bad feeling about somebody don't even
worry about being rude being like [__]
you dude and run the [__] away yeah and
it's like I mean because what's the
worst that can happen it's like you know
oh that guy yeah you hurt his dude's
feelings big deal some doodle pigs
better than better than you being dead
yeah isn't it some dude will pick him up
he can get in the back of the car yeah
back in the truck yeah it's fine that's
a it's like not the worst thing ever to
like be rude to somebody and have
somebody think you're an [__] it's
fine just let people think you're an
[__] it's it's cool better than being
dead just saying
um every time I've run across the
[__] this this [__]
doesn't feel right
Jenny can attest over time at the club
yeah that was a bad dude
[__] you know exactly the one that
I'm talking about on that one probably
started with a j
yeah that dude [__] there's a lot of
a lot of that [__] there's just when
somebody is up to no good
as long as you know people real well you
can get the feeling
there's something about the tone
the neediness in the [__] the the
like a false veneer there's just there's
no way I mean to be honest with you like
85 percent of people that I meet make me
uncomfortable
you know what I mean well you get to
where you can size people up I'm very
superficial what they're wearing this
and that [__] can a lot of these guys
who are mentalists they're not
mentalists and these serial killers they
can find people's weaknesses they're not
superhuman they're just very very
superficial
because you can tell a lot of people
about somebody if you're very
superficial and in Western culture they
train people not to be superficial well
the thing about it though is that most
people are not complicated I mean you're
not as complicated as you might think
you are like and I think too like a lot
of people are portraying a lot of things
to the world that they're not aware of
yeah like the way that they move their
body the way that they you know move
their hands the way they talk
yeah like what they're wearing like how
they're carrying themselves like that
and if you're observant like you can
pick up on a lot of that kind of stuff
dead giveaway people's shoes
from a person's shoes you can tell a lot
what brand they're wearing if they're
not wearing certain brands if their
shoes are [__] up if they're you know
if you can tell a lot by shoes
you can tell what a person does for a
living Hannibal Lecter had a whole thing
about that oh yeah oh yeah
yep it's true Hannah Montana did mention
that to you too you're cheap you and
your cheap shoes yeah yeah your good
suit and your cheap shoes yeah
right which he's spot on that's how they
do it
well yeah like I said it's you know
shoes are the last thing somebody buys
okay so that's the that's the giveaway
about income all right and that's the
giveaway about social status
uh which is why some low-income people
really stress out about shoes they'll
kill you over a certain pair of [__]
Sneakers but these are sneakers they're
spending that much money on sneakers
real successful person is not going to
worry about sneakers we're about Bally's
or certain kind of boots there are
combat boots out there that are 500
dollars
ain't that some [__] this is a
[__] is going to go into combat
and get killed most likely he's gonna
buy a 500 pair of boots they're great
boots but they're 500 they're not 500
great I can guarantee they're not 500
great in fact I can think of very few
things that are five hundred dollars
great best pair of boots I ever had was
a matterhorns and they were [__]
issued to me and that's about 250 pair
of boots I could see that but like I
said 500 man yeah that well that is like
the Gucci of combat they would have to
have like a parachute and a coffee maker
and like toilet paper and dispenser I
mean there would all have to be all kind
of [__] in there for that to be worth
well they're water very few things we've
got Gore-Tex in them they're waterproof
they're [__] still not worth 500 but
I don't think they'd [__] last as
much as you you can run in them and I
don't think they're that good but what
it is half my rent you're either so
[__] worth it the guy who's buying
this is either working for a company
making a [__] ton of money
or he's an armed chair commander who
wants to look like a dude who's making a
[__] ton of money in some kind of
[__] military Contracting type
company or security company you know
could be one of the two but the thing is
is that the dude that's in that security
company is also in a badass SUV with 20
other dudes and [__] they're they're
the Bodyguards of some famous [__]
politician or something you know what I
mean so you don't really need the boots
to [__]
depress anybody because you got other
[__] you know you got a [__]
submachine gun in a briefcase you got
all kinds of [__] well then you come
across somebody like me that doesn't
give a [__] about any of that stuff so
you know they're not it's not for you
it's foreign
I just give a [__] about if you're a
creep or not yeah Larry says by the way
guys I have two recommendations of
excellent modern Horrors for you
Barbarian 2022 and censor 2021 I have
seen both of those movies and they are
both fantastic I haven't seen anything
and actually I've done reviews on both
of them as well
um sensor was actually one of my
favorite movies of 2021. Jenny's told me
to watch Barbarian I didn't see it you
would probably like it I think okay I
think it's one of those movies where I
like it or hate him yeah you liked
malignant right I don't think I've ever
saw that one yeah we saw in the theater
which one was that that batshit crazy
one about the woman with the thing with
the bat on the back of her head she was
like walking backwards
you were we saw it
saw it we saw so many movies in the end
of that we saw in the theater like not
that long ago sitting on the back of her
head and she's walking backwards
no I don't think I saw that yeah you did
see it because you were sitting right in
[__] next to me we were in the
theater we saw in the theater I don't
remember it
we saw the theater you really liked it
you really liked it what did she have on
the back of her head
you know what I mean it was just kind of
like a whole like thing where her uh
yeah she had like a thing on the back of
her so it was like a um conjoined twin
type situation
spoiler alert
I don't remember that one and she was
like the killer the whole time
yeah I remember it yeah we saw it it
wasn't even that long ago
it wasn't even that long ago we saw that
we saw the theater I don't remember that
I but okay well that doesn't work then
because they don't remember anything I
was gonna say you liked malignant
because you did at the time because I
remember
um you would probably like Barbarian as
well okay it's one of those ones that
like it takes several like you know kind
of like hard left turns but I was kind
of into that all right I really liked it
um and like I said sensor more people
need to see that that was a great
[__] movie I really liked that movie
a lot that was probably like my favorite
one of my favorite movies of that year
if not my favorite
but unless okay sensor was good what was
the other one that I really liked there
was another one that came out in 2021
called come true that I really liked
also I think that was 2021 and then
there was another one that was either I
don't remember if it was 2021 or maybe
it was 2019 called in fabric if you like
like really really [__] weird ass
surreal movies that was [__] awesome
I really liked that
thank you Jeffy art I wonder what my
cowboy boots say to people many of them
can be uh in the I guess it's like
expensive yeah but I'll wear the [__]
out of them until they need to be resold
three times yeah so yeah well it means
you're a country [__] okay it means that
you uh you dress to impress other
country [__] you may have some money
but that's that damn rural money
now if you're in the city wearing those
[__] same expensive cowboy boots that
just means you're gay okay you're a gay
prostitute and you need a g string and
you put your ass up on top of that damn
box in the middle of the club with those
flashing lights on you and you have
another dude over there just [__]
lubricating up your nipples
he got it
Tom Sykes says Tom if you like that
Intruder film with Dennis Quaid which he
did he loved it yeah you'd like
Barbarian that's what I was thinking
it's
like I said it's I don't even want to go
so far as say it's a love it or hate it
because I don't think it's that weird
but it's like it does take a lot of hard
left turns that maybe but I liked that
because it went like a couple different
drives like oh okay we're doing this now
all right and it like went a couple
different directions and I really like
that but some people didn't like that
yeah I liked that though I thought it
was great Jeff what you need to do is
you need I know you got your chaps right
get your chaps and your cowboy hat and
your gun belt and all that kind of [__]
with the cowboy boots and uh make a
video and I'll send that into my [__]
uh my gay porn friend and if it's good
enough he'll put that up he'll put that
up in there with on his [__] site
Zach says my shoes are gay too yeah yeah
yeah
okay she is yeah gay shoes they're
always expensive expensive shoes usually
And Justice For Me said I saw your
Martyrs review yeah that movie is still
branded on my brain right it's like I'm
I'm glad I watched it but yeah there's
like stuff in there that I'm just like
well never gonna get that out of my head
great it's one of those kind of movies
I'm kind of like I don't know I'm like
maybe a masochist like that I kind of
feel the need I was watching a video the
other day by um what's that girl's
Channel's name uh possessed by horror
and she was making a video about like
[__] she was never gonna watch because
she's like look I got to a certain age
where she's like I know that like all
these horror fans are like oh you have
to see this and you have to see like all
this extreme horror or you're not a real
horror fan she's like [__] that I don't
want to watch any of this stuff so like
some of this stuff was like Antichrist
which was actually awesome I really
liked that movie and it didn't really
bother me all that much but some of the
stuff I was like in Cannibal Holocaust
which I get because there's a lot of
animal cruelty in that but I don't know
I kind of do feel the need to watch them
and martyrs was one that it took me a
really long time to watch because that
turns up on sing every single [__]
list of most disturbing horror movies
ever made and it is uh I'm not saying
it's not but I mean I've seen worse but
it's pretty [__] up it's pretty [__]
up so I don't know I I've got to a point
now where it's like you have to kind of
be okay with that stuff like being in
your head forever
and I guess I guess I am because I keep
watching the [__] you know what I mean
keep watching the [__]
um Tom Sykes said Crocs are the gay
issues all right so can I get back to
this [__] now yeah they're in their JFR
no they can talk talking about gay shoes
talk about gay shoes and dude man
[__] just just contact [__] uh Rob
Halford I I [__] talked to Rob
Halford over for Instagram okay he's the
gay guy man the gay leather daddy God
you really talk to him on Instagram yeah
yes I told him I said or somebody that
was pretending no no He's Got His
official I said Rob I grew up listening
to your [__] man going all about his sin
after sin you call yourself metal god
dude you just [__] God your voice is
[__] awesome man and he goes well
thank you very much you know just that's
all I said ass kisser yeah yeah
of course yeah yeah Rob's looking all
right man [__] old man he's [__]
just follow him on [__] Instagram man
he's [__] funny he's a nice guy
he always seemed like a nice guy living
out in Arizona in a desert
And Justice For Me says the French
Spanish South Koreans really take it to
the extreme the American movies are
paling in comparison yeah if you want to
see really [__] up [__] yeah watch
those horror movies and I like a lot of
American horror movies too but if you
want some real [__] up [__] yeah you
probably need to watch that stuff they
go there like American movies usually
don't I don't know why I don't know why
but
particularly French but I don't know
French movies are pretty [__] up
yeah South Korean movies [__] up
Spanish movies [__] up too I should
probably do more Spanish movies I've
seen a lot but I just I don't think I've
reviewed that many
there's actually one what the [__] was
that one called that I that I really
liked that I wanted to do
[__] man no I can't remember what it was
I saw it probably like a year ago and I
was like oh I gotta re-watch that
because I like that a lot and I wanted
to like um review it but you know
all right so where was I okay so I was
at the point where
people were seeing a ghost of somebody
standing on their porch saying that he
had to get the luggage and then
Vanishing
so um so yeah so all this weird [__] was
going on in this field where this plane
crashed so a lot of the people evidently
that lived in this trailer park were
like yeah this is getting too weird for
me and they moved out so like a lot of
people did like move away
um and so new people moved in
but the new people that moved in also
started reporting like weird [__]
happening too now one particular thing
that is very popularly reported was
apparently a guy I think he was one of
the guys that had like just moved there
like after one of the other people said
[__] this and moved out
so he's out in the trailer park like
walking his dog at night
and he's um you know kind of approaching
kind of near the area like where the uh
where the flight 191 crashed
and he like he said that a guy like a
young man walked up to him and said that
he needed to make an emergency phone
call
and so the guy is like looking at this
case he said it looked like a person
like it didn't look like you know he
wasn't like see-through or nothing like
that but he's just like he just saw this
dude and he just like looked at him and
he kind of was like that's really weird
because he said he he smelled like
gasoline and he said that he looked like
he was smoldering that's what he said
but he said otherwise like I guess he
just looked like a normal dude he didn't
look ghostly or nothing now so this guy
thinks it's a guy and he's just like
asking for help like he's asking for a
phone or something and he's like well
maybe the guy was just like you know
running around at night and it's kind of
cold out and it's like maybe his body
heat is like making
his you know making him steam or
something because it's like it looked
like that that's what he thought but he
turned around he's like oh there's a
phone over there like a pay phone over
there
and then he when he turned back the dude
was gone so that was one thing that the
that uh somebody reported now after that
like I guess this guy had heard some
stories about other people in the
trailer park that had seen
that had seen [__] and like heard weird
noises and stuff like coming from the
crash site but he had actually never
believed in them until he actually saw
this guy like just come up to him but
like I said he just looked like a normal
guy now the weird thing about this too
is that there were actually premonitions
about this particular crash apparently
before it even happened
so the most famous one was this guy
named David Booth and I saw like an
interview with him on uh this one
documentary
now he was not even from Chicago he was
from Cincinnati because the crash
happened in Chicago in case I didn't
mention that
um so yeah he was in Cincinnati and for
10 nights in a row in 1979
he had the same nightmare
in this nightmare he would see a plane
going off the Runway and then flip over
and explode or like you know catch on
fire
now he had this dream a bunch of times
and he's like and it wasn't like a dream
it was like a vision and it was the same
like every time so he's like I don't I
don't know if I should do this but he's
like I don't know what else to do so he
called the FAA so there is actually a
record of this
now he's like he called them up and he's
like they're just gonna laugh at me and
like hang up probably but he's like I
don't know what else to do like because
it seems like I should probably do
something about this so he calls up now
um to his surprise actually
um the guy the FAA who they also
interviewed on this particular
documentary that I saw
um he's like yeah he's like the guy
called he's like you didn't sound like a
kook or anything like that and he was
like look I know this is gonna sound
like really weird but I've been having
this same dream and it's all good he's
like and I'm sure it's American Airlines
because I saw the logo like in my dream
and everything and he described what the
plane looked like
um so from the way that he described the
plane
uh the guy at the FAA was like well
that's either a DC-10 or a Boeing 727
like you know because the engine
configurations and the tail and stuff
like that
um so basically you know he was like
well the fa was like well the problem is
that if you don't have like a location
or a time or anything like that it's
like there's really not
much actionable information because it's
like you know we have what thousands and
thousands of flights like every day like
all around the world and so there
wouldn't be any way to
kind of head that off you know what I
mean because it's like it could happen
anywhere
and like I said this guy wasn't even in
Chicago he was in
um you know he was in Cincinnati
now um he actually had this nightmare I
guess for the last time like on the
night of May 24th which was the night
before the morning that it happened
and in the interview that I saw he said
when he woke up that morning he somehow
knew that he wasn't gonna have the dream
anymore
and he I think I have a really strong
feeling
so
about an hour later like an hour or two
later like after he got up he went into
work and he got a phone call about an
hour later and the guy they said um yeah
turn on the TV uh there it is
and
That's like [__] they the thing about
it was the FAA they because they have to
do this in this every situation I guess
they investigated him
because somebody calling up before some
[__] happens and saying hey this plane's
gonna crash or something they're gonna
think yeah or you're a weirdo or maybe
you planted a bomb or some [__] like
that but you know it's pretty obvious he
didn't do anything and honestly like the
the interview that I saw with him he's
still [__] up about it because he's
sitting there going I wish I could have
done something but I didn't know what
time it was taking off I didn't know
what city it was taking off I didn't
know where it was but like the way that
it happened was almost exactly the way
that he had dreamed about
you know what I mean which is uh pretty
freaky when you think about it but he's
still like yeah he was like up really
busted up and he was like crying and
stuff and he's like I just wish I could
have done something but the guy from the
fa was like there's nothing he could
have done there's thousands and
thousands of flights there's no way we
could have narrowed that down
so
um and it also later transpired this is
kind of interesting that David Booth was
not the only person who had some kind of
I don't know if I'd call this
necessarily a premonition but it's kind
of like that
so you know uh Lindsay Wagner The Bionic
Woman yeah I haven't heard that name in
a long time yeah I love that show uh
Six Million Dollar Man noises so every
time they moved it went no no no no but
he got annoyed in like two seconds and
took it back out again
people
laughs
we're getting we're getting to that
point now where it's just kind of like
um you know how like when your
grandparents used to like say some crazy
[__] like about when they were and
you're like what the [__] are you even
talking about we're getting I think I
think we got mostly Gen X
uh Mega Badger says the [__] Dio is
God do
is not really God Dia was like God's
main sorcerer okay now Ronnie James D
was [__] awesome okay Tom's got the
whole hierarchy figured yeah there's a
whole heart at the top
at the top is Rob Halford you know just
by just by uh virtue of [__]
excessive masculinity and leather
dadiness he's going to be at the top
no but I always like to
um Judas Priest I just thought they were
overall the best metal band not all
their albums were [__] really good
but they were better than Iron Maiden if
Iron Maiden over time went bad
the last really good Iron Maiden album
was probably like Somewhere in Time
but there were some bad [__] Judas
Priest albums but most of them were good
I'd say [__] Judas Priest ran that
show
Tom Sykes said I've had a precognitive
dream before of a shooting at a park
that didn't happen until a month later
but in the dream it took a place the
next street over which was freaky yeah
that's kind of like an I don't know if
we've ever done a show about like
precognitive dreams but I remember
a lot of people saying that they dreamed
about one that I remember like in
particular because I think I was in
Wales and I remember like hearing a lot
about this was the aberfan the abervan
disaster like where the um the cult all
the coal slurry like slid off the
mountain and like went over the school
and like suffocated all the people all
the kids
um and they said that a lot of people
had a premonition about that like a few
nights before it happened so I'm always
kind of like interested in that kind of
thing I don't know if I necessarily
believe in her if it's just like
coincidence or anything I don't think
I've ever had anything like that happen
especially
but I mean you probably I think you
probably had some stuff like that too
have you ever read any precognitive
Dreams yeah yeah dreaming true on a
regular
well what in particular like have you
dreamed and then it came true later
day before the 9 11 happened oh yeah a
lot of people said they had that too day
before 9 11 happened
I had a dream that somebody was in a
damn male jet like a DC-10 type male jet
and um crashed it into a building but I
don't remember what the building was
uh it wasn't a skyscraper building or
something flat like a mall like a
shopping mall
so close next day 9 11 him
that's pretty weird yeah and like I said
I think a lot of people like yeah
um said they had premonitions about that
when I was a kid I would have dreams of
what my parents were going to tell me
and the next day they would tell me some
[__]
and it was just like Off the Wall stuff
um
the weirdest thing that was ever like
that before and I told this story before
I was at home
I think I stayed in from school that day
this is that when I was in California it
was in I was on Jackson Street in Carson
right outside was when I went to
Dominguez Elementary School
I think I stayed home from school that
day and all of a sudden I got startled
and heard the phone ring
and ran to the phone and picked up a
phone and heard two people talking
and it sounded like my Aunt Ruthie
and somebody else talking and um
I heard a conversation between two
people a man and a woman
and I hadn't seen my Aunt Ruthie in a
long time
and then I was trying to I was going
hello hello hello and they wouldn't
answer and then finally it stopped they
stopped talking and I put the phone down
went back to the television
a few minutes later as I was standing in
front of the television somebody pulled
up in the driveway was Aunt Ruthie
and I said I just heard I just heard you
on the telephone and she was like yeah
yeah because I was a little kid she
didn't
she didn't know I was talking about she
goes get in the car bus we'll get
something to eat we're hungry we'll wait
for your mom to come back home I was
like all right they were from they were
from Escondido it was a long way away
over an hour
so we go to spiers restaurant and on the
way there
I hear her and her new husband talking
and they had the same conversation I
heard on the phone
and I said I heard you guys talking
about this over the phone
and they just laughed and blew me off
and kept on talking
because I was like like how weird though
that like it's so weird that's why I
kind of think there's really no
intentionality about it I think it's
just kind of like a glitch in The Matrix
situation because it's like whenever
people have premonitions like I said
like the guy David Booth if he had the
premonition about flight 191 crashing
beforehand and he kept having it like he
had it 10 nights in a row according to
him so it's like obviously if some
greater intelligence was trying to tell
him hey do something about this it's
like well hey you have to give me more
information than that and he wasn't even
in the right he wasn't even in the same
city he wasn't even so it just seemed
like a random here's the weird thing
remember I told you when I told you I
heard them talking talking about me on
the phone all right talk about me but
they did mention me I'm coming I think
if I remember correctly but I heard them
have that conversation when I was saying
hello hello hello they weren't answering
and the voices just faded away like the
volume got turned down low
and when I was had my hand on the phone
I was waiting for it to be like a busy
signal or a dial tone or something and
it was nothing
and I just had this real ominous feeling
of like fear came over me
so I just hung up the phone like that
was weird what was that but were they
they weren't talking about anything like
upsetting or nothing normal [__] but but
the voices faded away over the phone
and I'm like I'm just holding a dead
phone in my hand I don't think that that
phone ever rang
yeah I think I hallucinated that that
phone rang
and had a premonition while I was on the
phone with the phone next to my ear I
don't think there was anything
yeah maybe that yeah I just think I was
getting the download
but it was weird it was like I was a
little kid you know yeah I mean pretty
random yeah just random [__] and like I
said it wasn't even important [__] no
but I was sense in the future do animals
do this
maybe so
like I said maybe maybe some people can
tuned it but like I said it doesn't
really seem like there's any
intentionality because anybody that's
ever reported they had precognitive [__]
it's yeah sometimes it's about important
things but it's never
specific enough to prevent [__] it seems
like it was important to me because it
was based on the emotion
you know what I'm talking about yeah
most like yeah yeah they're here you
know that kind of stuff
yeah I'm just saying that it wasn't like
what was important was just subjective
it would be important to a child yeah
you know
that's the force man
all right so where was I all right so
Lindsay Wagner The Bionic Woman
she was actually supposed to be on this
flight plate 191. on May 25th which
crashed and killed everyone aboard
now according to her
um she was actually waiting for the
plane but started feeling really really
sick yeah and the closer it got to like
the time to get on the plane she's like
man I just feel like [__] and she's like
I you know she thought that when she got
on the plane she was gonna like you know
throw up or get really sick on it so
she's like [__] this I'm just gonna like
you know go some other time so she just
went back home and she said as soon as
she left the airport she felt a lot
better
so uh so yeah so she came out later and
said uh said that also
um I found I dug this up as well uh some
also believe that the flight number
itself 191 is uh unlucky just on its own
for example let's talk a little bit
about this case because this isn't
necessarily anything to do with ghosts
but this is some crazy [__] and I
remember when this happened too because
this was only in uh 2012.
so 2012
there was the case of JetBlue Airways
flight 191. and that had to be diverted
to Amarillo Texas because the captain
whose name was Clayton Osborne
he got locked out of the cockpit by the
first officer his name was Jason Dowd uh
and was also subdued by the passenger
like the passengers like tackled him and
like tied him up with [__] seat belts
and [__] like that because he started
acting like a crazy person so you know
that's another thing that you have to
like [__] think about when you're
flying in a plane that your pilot might
just suddenly like flip his [__] [__]
like this dude did
so he yeah he just was apparently like
normal up until the time
and then on this particular day he gets
on the flight
and then he just starts ranting he
starts ranting about 9 11. he starts
ranting about terrorists he had some
kind of thing and uh basically what
ended up happening was that the first
officer he's like the captain they're in
the cockpit doing their you know normal
flight [__] and he starts getting a
little bit alarmed when the captain has
start saying start saying stuff like we
need to take a leap of faith and we're
not going to Vegas because that's where
the flight was supposed to go I can't be
responsible when this plane crashes like
he was saying [__] like that which
yeah no I I don't think that's that's
gonna happen no
so um and then he started talking about
Jesus and terrorists and there's a bomb
on this plane and blah blah
so the first officer [__] hero he's
basically like hey um why don't you go
into the passenger Cabaret I don't know
what exactly what he said to him you
just go into the passenger compartment
for a sec just for a second just like
step out the [__] door there for a
second and then like once the captain
left the cockpit and went out of the
pastor think he slams the door and he
like changed the security code so the
dude could get back in and then
basically like once the passengers
figured out what was going on they
[__] piled on the dude and just like
tied him up like with um
with uh you know uh seat belts and stuff
like that I mean yeah he was just
FL he flipped his [__] he flipped his
[__]
so um basically they had to divert the
plane like I said the plane was actually
going to Las Vegas uh but they were you
know understandably they were like yeah
let's land at the nearest airport which
was Amarillo Texas so uh when the plane
landed they rightfully so arrested osbon
and arrested him with interference with
a flight crew
so he had actually worked for JetBlue
for 12 years and like I said the dude
was totally normal apparently like up to
this point but he was just like on the
plane and he just flipped the [__] out
and started like ranting about Jesus and
how there's a bomb on the plane and [__]
so you know and his first officer was
like yeah no not having that one I'm
walking out of the [__] cockpit so
they did and then also all the
passengers tackled him so I thought that
was pretty cool too
uh but yeah maybe he dropped acid I
don't really know what his [__]
problem was man
um but yeah he was he was getting to a
thing where it's like we're not gonna go
to Vegas and he's like he was gonna
crash the plane on purpose or some [__]
because some Pilots have done that so
you know that's another thing you gotta
[__] worry about another reason I
don't want to fly anymore
so um basically they so he got arrested
they put him on trial and they found
that he was uh a [__] Looney Tunes so
they put him essentially well sir are
Looney Tunes well yeah that's that's the
uh the medical term yeah it's like a
medical term but basically they're like
all right well he didn't get any jail
time because of that because they're
like a reason of insanity
so they actually put him in a mental
health facility in North Carolina
but later on they did actually free him
but they said well obviously he's not
allowed to fly planes anymore and
they're like well you have to keep on
with your treatment you have to you know
stay on your meds and you know he had to
they had to like monitor him basically
because he was like flipping the [__]
out
interestingly though three years later
after this incident like the plane
landed like I said they were diverted it
was fine like the first officer hero you
know what I mean he got they got the
plane landed everyone was fine
um but this was also flighting up 191 so
you can see why people were like
thinking maybe that number was cursed so
basically though the captain three years
after this [__] happens because I was
like this is [__] ballsy he sued
JetBlue for 15 million dollars
the basis of his lawsuit was that the
airline didn't ensure that he was fit to
fly
that's why he sued yeah y'all didn't
check me out before you let me fly so
it's your fault
that's a good grift that I'm crazy well
he got the idea apparently because
remember like back in 2015
um there was that one uh that German
Wings flight 9525 and that the co-pilot
actually deliberately crashed the plane
and killed everybody on board so I guess
that's where he got the idea from
so he's like oh well I'm gonna Sue too
and like say well you guys should have
known that I was nuts and shouldn't have
even let me on the plane it's all your
fault
um so yeah I don't think that worked
there was like a settlement oh yeah yeah
well they didn't really give the divulge
the problem so I don't know if like
somebody got paid or I don't know
probably a lot they probably gave him a
lot but I was like what kind of [__]
[__] lawsuit is that well an attorney
probably told him to do that [__]
ball just listen what you should do is
just coming over this angle you'll
[__] win all kinds of money and we'll
split it like oh okay yeah let's do that
teaching crazy
um but yeah if you go to war always have
[__] lawyers with you okay
for this thing and I was like well what
was the problem like what caused him to
flip out because apparently he'd been
working for JetBlue for 12 years and
nobody suspected anything was weird
um they don't know
they said maybe he just like
sudden onset psychotic disorder he had
some kind of like a movie and a stroke
or
maybe he was on some kind of new meds
that were reacting weird or something
he said that he thought it was maybe a
seizure but I don't know man
maybe like I said that could have been
anything yeah but that's not your brain
that's what I mean a lot of my stroke
that [__] did that's [__]
terrifying like the dude that's flying
your [__] plane yeah I'll stay on the
ground thanks
um acid flashback Maybe
[__]
that's pretty scary though that just
like some normal ass [__] that's
been flying planes for 12 years and then
all of a sudden it's like I'm gonna
[__] crash this [__] into the ground
maybe it was just a whole retirement
plan
you know what I mean we're like if I do
this and that I'll have a good lawsuit
then I'll I won't have to work anymore
maybe that's what it was maybe he was
just tired of working and he just wanted
to flame out in the most like dramatic
way possible yeah and he's just like I'm
just gonna go crazy because he didn't
actually do anything he just started
saying crazy [__] and his first officer
was like yeah get the [__] out of my
cockpit right now yeah
because yeah that's not funny you almost
understand the power and the the the
power of [__] corruption all right
a person can think about some [__] and
go yeah I'm gonna throw this [__]
sideways and make all kinds of money I'm
sick of coming to work it's out there
yeah I mean it doesn't work
I mean I kind of feel like a gamble I
mean you only hear about the times when
it does work yeah so I kind of feel like
it probably only works probably about in
five percent of the time you have to be
a genius the rest of the time
everybody's being like knock that [__]
off what are you doing that's not that's
not gonna work out I gotta feel like
most of the time it's not gonna work
yeah
you know what I mean
mango says Yep this is why I do not fly
Nutter pilots and Nutter passengers yeah
pretty much nah for a long many times
there's no problems
well there's no problems until there is
a problem that's what I mean you never
know probably that's what I mean like
all of them and ride a motorcycle well
it is but at least if you're on a
motorcycle at least you're on the
[__] ground like I said I don't like
the idea of being and I don't like the
idea of being like trapped in this
little tube in the sky with a bunch of
[__] crazy people you know what I
mean I don't like that idea and you
can't escape it's not like you can just
jump out the window the sky isn't the
problem the ground's a problem well done
okay that's what I'm saying on a
motorcycle the relationship but you're
on the ground you're on the ground
moving around that's where all the
danger is
but I would rather that because I can at
least people are afraid of falling yeah
I don't like that's what I mean that's
the idea that I don't like that idea
yeah I don't like that idea and I also
just don't like I don't like the idea of
not having control of being like because
like I said you're in this tube in the
sky and you can't do a [__] thing
like if something goes wrong you're like
you can't do anything you can't do
anything to fix it you can't help in any
way you can't do anything you're just
kind of like [__] so I don't like that
I understand I mean I have that natural
fear of falling you know
uh but we used to fly in choppers with
the doors open and look outside [__]
doubt going [__] near to 200 miles an
hour if I can spit out the side [__]
doing dip and [__]
and it was it's all cool it does it
doesn't bother me at all I can hang my
feet over the [__] sides of the deck
on a uh one or a uh-60 it didn't matter
I didn't have the feeling
of being up high in the same way it was
compared to say climate but extremely
tall ladder like an aerosol school or
[__] hanging my head off of a [__]
top of a 20-story building it's very
different
because you have perspective
and that perspective of [__] with your
mind like you see I see a dude [__]
walking a tightrope between two
buildings and [__] get I get vertigo
but I never had that sensation in a
helicopter or an aircraft
it's just a different game you know I
have no problem jumping on out of a
[__] helicopter or an airplane as
long as I had a parachute on it would
just be normal to me I've never done it
but I would just go yeah okay and just
step out
but I couldn't jump off the top of a
building
don't ask me why it's just because
there's perspective there I guess
yeah you haven't been in that situation
so I I guess you can't really relate to
I know I'm not as cool as you well no
you haven't you can't relate to that yes
the edge of a building looking down whoa
whoa whoa I know I hate that but I could
look out the door of a helicopter be
five times higher and it's just like
well it's not I mean it's it's nothing
you know it's not exactly the same thing
like it's still high but it's not
exactly the same thing I'd be even
higher in a chopper but you just don't
have the perspective things just look
far away the weird thing about it is
like what Zach was saying earlier about
being on the little puddle jumpers for
some reason I think that being on the
smaller plane the plane that I was on
like that because I would fly from
Denver to Santa Fe that plane I think it
was an eight eight passenger I want to
say it was eight passenger
um so it was so it was pretty small I
think that even though it rattled around
a lot that didn't bother me as much as
being in a big one I don't and I don't
know why it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't make any sense
because I guess the the illusion that it
was more like I was in a car maybe
so I could maybe present easier I don't
know I don't know what it was because I
thought it would bother me more but once
I got on there I'm like well this is
bothering me like it still bothered me
but it bothered me significantly less
than being like on a big jet it's funny
which is dumb because like being on a
big jet is way more dangerous and like
intellectually or being on a big jet is
a lot safer is what I meant than like
being on a small plane like and being in
a small plane is still pretty safe but
in in the you know you know the taxonomy
of like safety usually the big jumbo
jets are the safest but I don't know I
just I don't like I don't like that
feeling and I don't like that feeling of
just being trapped in there and it just
I don't know I don't know what it is
it's just like a weird I've never liked
it like I said I know I'm sorry I'm not
cool and stuff like that but I know I'm
just you know I just I don't I don't
like it I don't like it I don't like I
don't like heights of any kind and I
especially don't like that and I think
the thing I think the thing I don't like
about it and I think the thing a lot of
people don't like about air line travel
is the lack of control when you're
driving a car obviously driving a car is
much more dangerous than flying in a
plane I mean that's just statistically
that is obviously very true and I know
that but driving a car I have control
I'm on the ground it's like if something
goes wrong I can at least try to avoid
it or I could try to do something to fix
it when I'm in a plane I can't do jack
[__] and I don't really like that
feeling
I don't have a sense of okay this is
where me and Jenny are going to differ I
don't have a sensation of danger or
falling when I'm involved in any kind of
aircraft I only have it when I'm on top
of something like a building
or
a really tall ladder that's like three
or four stories tall like those guys
that climb up those ladders on the sides
of water towers to go up there and
change light bulbs on top of antennas uh
that would yeah I'd be like yeah that
light's gonna stay out I'm not good
because you're climbing up that side
ladder and you're looking down going oh
[__] I'd probably be trembling halfway
up but I have no problem hanging out off
this out of the side I don't think
there's any amount of money you could
pay me to get me to do that
and I definitely couldn't [__]
tightrope walk no there's two buildings
way even if it was [__] six feet wide
you could say you were gonna give me a
billion dollars and I don't think I
would do it even if it's six feet wide
I'm not sure I could walk across that
you know like
top of like between the two World Trade
Centers when they were standing I don't
think I could do it no I don't think I
could do that like I said you could
probably come and say I'll give you a
billion dollars and I'd be like I don't
think I could
there's something about forward motion
and being inside of an aircraft that
kind of alleviates my and there's no
perspective there isn't a wall to look
down
you know
yeah I'm not standing on anything that's
solid
I'm inside of something I think too my
problem might be that I'm too good at
imagining worst case scenarios I don't
know I don't know maybe that's what it
is because I'm just like well because I
could because immediately when I get on
a plane I immediately think of all of
the horrible things that have gone wrong
all of the plane crashes that I've heard
about all of the movies that I've seen
that happen I don't even think about it
like that like well I can't that's just
how my brain works I can't stop it
I don't even think about it I can't stop
it
so maybe that's why because I'm thinking
about how because
and and I was thinking this too I
thought this today while I was reading
about flight 191 and I was thinking to
myself all those people that when I got
on the plane were probably thinking the
same [__] I think this every single
time I get on a flight there's like
everybody's like oh it's like oh it's
gonna be okay like oh it FL these
flights go like thousands of times a day
and it's totally fine and blah blah blah
and I said yeah all those people were
probably thinking that too and now
they're all dead
yeah your perspective is is wonky though
you know what I mean if I can no but
it's true the chances of you being on
one of those flights right there is very
that's probably what they thought too
yeah it's the same thing it's the same
thing with the lobby that's what they
thought too it's the same thing with all
the lottery have these people well I'm
gonna get this lottery ticket there's no
way I could [__] ever win the lottery
it would be like winning the lottery you
know I know but like I said that you you
tell me that like I don't know I do know
that but then my the my brain the next
thing it says is that yeah that's what
all those people thought too and now
they're all dead
so I can't help think that that's just
the way my brain works that's what I
like playing
you know what I mean
um yeah so this [__] Okay so he
[__] sued and uh like I said there
was a settlement they didn't really
release that to the public so like I was
saying there was some other weird [__]
that happened with other flight 191s not
American Airlines but um other Airlines
flights
so there was also a Delta Airlines
flight 191 which actually crashed it was
caused by wind shear actually and that
crashed um on landing at Dallas Fort
Worth uh International Airport in 1985
and that killed 137 people and that
included one dude who was on the ground
um so because Delta had a flight 191
that crashed and American Airlines had a
flight 191 that crashed
um neither one and I don't know if this
is still true to this day like
um maybe but I they don't have that
flight number anymore because that's
usually what they do because it's like a
superstitious thing is that if a flight
crashes then that Airline will retire
that flight number just because like I
said it's people are going to be
superstitious about it nobody wants to
be on the same it doesn't make any sense
it's not you know it's not
scientifically valid but
even I who knows that that's like
[__] and Superstition I still would
be like I don't know if I want to get on
a flight like numbered that like didn't
we are although maybe the maybe the odds
would be better because it's like well
one that was a number that's already
crashed so maybe the odds are better
like I said it doesn't make any sense
it's not it's not scientifically valid
but yeah I get why because it's like you
don't want to be on the same [__]
number
now because uh flight 191 had crashed
the American Airlines one and um as I
mentioned before like because a few
other dc-10s had crashed there was
actually one in 1972 which is also dc10
and that was also an American Airlines
flight that was flight 96.
um and that crashed because of its cargo
doors and then there was also a Turkish
Airlines flight uh that happened in 1974
that was also a DC-10 that was flight
981 and it crashed for like similar
reasons so because of that like the
dc-10s were a lot of the crashes have
been caused by the same kind of like
slip shot maintenance procedure that
they had found in the 191 thing so they
actually did do something about it and
they went back and said look you can't
do that [__] anymore where you just like
pull the [__] engine and the pylon
down on the forklift and do that kind of
crap because obviously we're gonna have
planes crashing all over the place it's
called an engine swap that's well you
know what I mean so they were having all
of that kind of stuff well no they said
that if you're if you're going to do
engine maintenance you have to take the
whole assembly apart yeah instead of
taking the whole thing off in one piece
like you weren't supposed to take the
whole thing off in one piece yes it's
easier yes it takes like less time but
that's how you get crashes and we don't
want crashes so they basically said you
can't do that anymore
um and American Airlines got fined like
half a million dollars which in those
days money which is about uh one and a
half million like nowadays uh for you
know so they got fined for that because
of it was their maintenance it wasn't
you know anybody that was on the plane
um and also for a time about two weeks
after the accident
um they actually grounded all dc-10s for
uh for a little while like until they
could figure out like what the problem
was so they did that for a little while
and I think it was like maybe like a
month or something they kept all the DC
tones on the ground so they did that
um now in October actually it was
Halloween of 1979 a another DC-10 that
was flying as Western Airlines flight
2605 uh crashed in Mexico City uh coming
from Los Angeles like Los Angeles and
Mexico City uh now that was actually due
to that wasn't due to any like
maintenance issues or mechanical issues
that was like low visibility and the
pilots had become confused and were
trying to land on a closed Runway
so that was what it caused that so that
was more like pilot error and like you
know atmospheric conditions
um but you also had a DC-10 that was a
Air New Zealand flight that was 901 and
that was November 28 1979 and that
crashed and killed 257 people that hit a
mountain
um and that was kind of mostly human era
and environmental error as well
now interestingly uh there was another
DC-10 crash 10 years after that United
Airlines flight 232.
but it actually ended up that this crash
um actually got some of their reputation
back because for a while like nobody
wanted to fly on dc10s because it seemed
like they were crashing every [__]
week
now this particular crash the aircraft
lost an engine and all the flight
controls
and crash landed in a huge [__]
explosion which a news crew caught on
video
the crash killed 112 people but
184 people survived so in some ways
people were like oh well that's [__]
up that like a bunch of people died and
the [__] [__] fell out of this guy
and exploded but 184 people lived so
maybe dc-10s aren't so bad after all
which is
I don't know damning with faint praise I
guess but it's kind of like that but so
yeah so after this particular accident
or like series of accidents
um orders for dc-10s were like way down
after that
um and they basically only made them for
10 more years and during those 10 years
the biggest uh orders of dc-10s were the
cargo plays like FedEx and the the Air
Force so basically they uh they were
passenger Airlines for a little while
but then they discontinued them as
passenger Airlines in 1988. so there's
that because and it was largely because
of all the crashes you know what I mean
probably time to take a break you think
yeah I gotta pee as well okay now go
ahead and put through the commercials do
you know where they are uh I can't see
I don't know so you don't even have your
glasses I have my glasses on all right
all right so we're gonna do some
commercials and then when we come back
when we come back we're gonna talk about
flight 401 yeah the ghosts of flight
forward and for those of you who are
watching this recorded we have that damn
new feature what's it called uh super
thanks super thanks we were accepting
super thanks it's kind of like a super
chat but it's a it's it's a it's a is a
late Super Chat
super thanks I'm gonna make a [__]
shirt called super thanks
yeah yeah it'd be nice yeah super thanks
baby
I like that I like that term that's a
good idea well it's because there are
other stuff is called Super Chat and
then they have another thing that's
called super something else
YouTube's trying to up its game you know
what I mean it needs more Revenue so P
they make a lot of money off of super
chats because they get some of that
money
and people make a lot of videos so
they're missing out on the [__] that's
already recorded you might as well be
able to give a super chat on the [__]
that's recorded too so that's a good
idea because a lot of our favorites yeah
like another time zones yeah so they
can't watch us live
so I like that the super thanks I
thought was a good great idea
yeah
but uh okay go ahead and well and they
have memberships too and I'm thinking
about
um which is kind of like a similar setup
to patreon yeah so I'm kind of thinking
about maybe doing that too just like
yeah yeah and we also we're also looking
for patrons patrons on patreon that's
true yeah yeah so uh let's go ahead and
do the commercials and we'll be back
with you guys in a second we'll be back
in just a minute
oh
[Music]
my God
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
and now was acknowledged the presence
[Music]
is
expired
[Music]
and darkness
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're back once again hopefully you had
a good break there talk about what we're
gonna eat when the show's over well yeah
everybody knows that
I got some fresh bit uh biscuit
biscuit dough ready I can make biscuits
at any time and I got that crunchy gravy
already made I can make biscuits and
gravy that's another shirt you need it's
like I can make biscuits at any time
make biscuits at any time
never know when Biscuit's gonna happen
when biscuits could appear yeah biscuits
could happen with anything with [__]
butter jelly on them they could have
gravy on them they have sausage in there
sausage with cheese
you just keep like rubbing all your
facial hair yeah I'm being a Sinister oh
okay
well I got hair so I'm gonna [__] with
it okay
he and England said any of y'all ever
watch vampires kiss yes we actually
reviewed it how long it wasn't that long
ago I feel like the one with the um
Nicholas Cage Nicholas Cage yeah yeah it
was good good foot
yeah it's hilarious
um yeah I think we reviewed it just like
he's got a new vampire movie coming out
gotta see that Renfield Renfield yeah
with uh Nicholas Holt from uh who's nux
from
Fury Road yeah Mad Max Fury Road yeah
they [__] us over on um Mad Max
should have been a new one by now well
it takes a while or a furiosa maybe
we'll see I'm gonna see if there's
anything coming I'd be I'd be down for a
furious yeah but to see a furious movie
but Tom Hardy's Max he was [__] great
I thought he was good I mean they could
do I kind of wish they'd do another
movie with both of them to be honest I
really liked their their Synergy yeah
you could probably bring them together
somehow like they did yeah a long time
well like I said it's the end of the
movie she was just kind of like hey man
he's like yeah hey man like thinking
she's still a laugh though he's
antisocial you know he I know but it's
like it's not like he could go super far
right you know what I mean it's like
they'd still be the Citadel had all the
water and all the food right that's what
I mean so I just kind of feel like yeah
that they could do that easy yeah
just saying I'm just saying I really
liked Mad Max Fury Road and I wouldn't
mind seeing like more stuff like that
yeah
yeah he said okay no [__] please don't
sit back
I mean I haven't like my light hasn't
gone it looks okay coming back
okay
maybe it's just [__] well I'm worried
because we lost our internet earlier
today like this morning like it was
probably like 11ish yeah the community
said that it was going to be it was
going to be out today oh okay so I
didn't get that memo yeah so I was just
like what the [__] so was that like half
an hour and I was just like Jesus Christ
I couldn't maybe longer longer a couple
hours yeah because we kind of live a
little bit like a little bit out in the
sticks so we have what's it called
Optical tell
yeah that's like the the Wi-Fi for this
there's a lot of construction around
here because it's expanding we're on the
edge of Orlando well yeah I mean this is
now on the edge we're about yeah but I
mean we're about 20-ish 28 miles from
downtown Orlando yeah but we're like
suburbs of Orlando but rural rural
suburbs right where we used to live we
we used to be the rural suburbs now
that's [__] suburbs yeah you know
it's expanding
so now we're at where we were 10 years
ago but I mean our Wi-Fi is usually
pretty good but yeah for some reason
like it went out today but we heard like
because I'm on the little the community
board for uh black bear Reserve where we
live and they're just like yeah they
told us it was going to be out today
because they were doing some work or
whatever but it was out for like half an
hour and I was freaking out because I
didn't get that memo until like later so
you know
um yeah so let's talk about flight 401.
here's this other one so actually this
happened a little bit uh earlier than
the other one that we talked about this
was in 1972 December 29th this was man I
was only a few months old
so this was a different uh Airline this
was Eastern which I don't even they're
not even around anymore are they
it was it's not even Eastern Airlines I
think they're just called Eastern yeah I
don't know Eastern flight I haven't
really been paying attention lately I
haven't either but like I said I don't
even know which ones and I haven't taken
I haven't flown anywhere for a really
long time so I couldn't tell you what
airlines are still around or not
um so yeah so this flight was going from
New York to Miami
so it took off from JFK Airport uh at 9
20 P.M
there were
176 people on board that's 163
passengers and 13 crew members now the
plane was not a DC-10 this time it was
actually a Lockheed
l1011 which is called The Whisper liner
because it's like super quiet
so 11 30 p.m they start making their
descent into uh Miami International
Airport
11 42 so 12 minutes after the captain
says hey we're starting to make our
descent into Miami the plane crashed
into the Everglades at 225 miles per
hour that's a wrap
yeah that's a wrap
so the speed wouldn't get you the
alligators would yeah well and the
[__] up thing about this like some
people like more people survived in this
than died I mean a lot of people died
I'm not saying that but like more bills
are right and some of the people that
survived the crash drowned yeah so
great yeah that's what I mean like you
are starting to worry about people
alligators too well I mean if you even
if you know if you're injured yeah you
can't even if you know how to swim yeah
you can still drown right I mean you're
getting injured don't ever don't be
victim blaming and [__] yeah
what I mean depends on the situation
if you're all busted up you can't put
broken arms and legs you can't swim
that's what I mean kind of hard to swim
when all of your limbs are broken yeah
or when you're unconscious right you
know so just saying like I said don't
blame the [__] victim
so uh so yeah
now apparently this flight had been like
pretty uneventful
but I guess when the flight was coming
in like doing its approach to Miami
the flight crew had started to kind of
become preoccupied by
um a faulty warning light
I see it yeah he just ignore that [__]
well I can't ignore it if it's just okay
if it goes out it's back all right
what the [__] man
some [__] that's what happens when
you live out in the middle of nowhere
all right
where was I okay and also the flight
engineer whose name was Don repo as in
Repo Man
so they got a warning light that said
that the landing gear wasn't working
correctly which you know that's bad when
you're trying to land the plane
so the pilot tells the co-pilot hey why
don't you put the plane on autopilot um
and then they sent the flight engineer
down to check and see what the [__] was
going on with the landing gear like you
know to check it manually
now what ended up happening they found
out after the accident
was that the pilot had accidentally
nudged the control yoke
um maybe with his knee or something like
because he when he turned around to talk
to the co-pilot or whatever like he must
have hit it and not noticed
and what happened with this was that the
autopilot mode was
set to follow whatever pitch the pilot
set with the Yoke so if you hit it into
a particular position without realizing
it
um then that's what the plane would do
which you know is probably not the best
idea
so and the thing about it was that the
because they didn't realize because it
was dark out it was night and they
didn't realize because they were so
worried about it's like hey is this
landing gear like working right and
they're down there trying to check it
and so they didn't realize that they
were going down like much faster and in
the wrong place
um so they didn't really figure out that
they were crashing until it was like too
late to fix it which is
[__] up
um because apparently like the co-pilot
kind of turned around and like saw the
thing you know the the indicator of
their altitude and was like oh [__] but
you know there really wasn't
um anything you could do about it at
that point oh another thing I forgot to
mention this I don't know why I didn't
why was this wasn't in my notes I forgot
to mention this when we were talking
about the previous case about flight
191.
um you know the the cockpit voice
recorder yeah they did recover that but
they said the weird thing about that and
this is the last flight we're talking
about
um they said the only literally the only
thing that was on there was the co-pilot
going damn
that's it yeah
that's it like so they really didn't
have hardly any indication and that like
free I don't know why that freaked me
out so much but that freaked me out a
lot and like I said it was just like the
way he said like damn
and then yeah the [__] plane exploded
so they really didn't have much
indication they're like some [__]
they saw something on those dials
but they couldn't do anything about it
because it was just like happened too
quick so yeah I can't believe I forgot
to mention that because I'm pretty
afraid sure that was the flight 191 I
forgot to mention that was the only
thing that was on The Voice Recorder
well because they were happy that they
recovered it because they're like oh my
you know maybe this will tell us like
before they had figured out like what
had gone wrong you saw something and
there's like literally all that was on
there was the guy going damn yeah and
that was it and I'm just like oh my God
that's horrible
okay so uh so what it made sense that
had you been there well yeah I know that
but it's like it's still creepy yeah
it's still creepy so it's crazy it's
yeah it's all that shit's always creepy
it's just it's situational he saw
something they saw something on the
[__] instruments there was [__]
weird as [__] maybe he looked in the
rear view mirror and saw the engine
going yeah
and that's it yeah that was all she
wrote yeah but yeah so uh all right so
back to flight 401.
so yeah they didn't actually realize
that they were descending into the
[__] swap until it was kind of too
late to do anything about it so the
plane crashes into the everblades now
um because I mean I guess luckily for
some of the people on the plane
um they crashed into the water and it
wasn't like a real severe angle
so a bunch of people did survive now
unfortunately that did not include the
pilot the co-pilot or the flight
engineer all of whom uh died in the
crash
so 75 people survived
uh but 101 people on the plane died
including as I mentioned the captain the
flight engineer uh and oh I actually I
think the the uh co-pilot actually maybe
lived but the pilot and the flight
engineer died he's lucky because I
always heard that if you're up in the
nose you're a goner it's a statistic I
always heard yes statistically it's
better to be towards the back of the
plane you see the people in the Tails
have the [__] best survival rates
but that that's just maybe it's just
statistics or well yeah because well I
guess because if a plane's gonna hit the
earth like probably the front well the
front of it usually hits first which
slows everything else down right so that
kind of makes sense maybe yeah or when
it hits that's nosed up because they're
trying to slow down so you have further
to fall after the explosion I don't
[__] know I don't know I don't know
but I have heard that it's like that
it's better yeah towards the back don't
be over one of the Wings that's like
that's probably not good either nose or
Wing probably yeah
yeah I kind of feel like it's probably
better just to be back then I know
people complain just like I don't want
to be in the back that's like by the
bathrooms but still
what I mean that's win-win bathroom is
close and if you get in a crash you
maybe won't die I mean you probably
still will but you maybe won't I don't
know
uh but yeah
so
75 people
uh survived 101 people died
now the ghost stories about flight 401
notably
didn't start until about four years
later we'll get into this
what happened was that in 1976 four
years after the plane crashed a guy
named John G Fuller
published a book called The Ghost of
flight 401.
now in this book he basically had all of
these interviews and stuff like that
with
flight Crews and like supposedly
surviving passengers and things like
that
and the story that they were all telling
was that they were seeing apparitions of
the captain captain Loft and the flight
engineer repo
um showing up on board other Eastern
Airlines planes
now apparently okay so how this all
started
now a later plane which was also
um an l1011 which is like the same model
as the plane that crashed and it was
also Eastern Airlines
so this particular plane was supposedly
on a flight to Mexico City like after
this after the other when it crashed
one of the flight attendants said that
they looked at the window of an oven in
the galley of the plane
and saw a man's face looking back at her
in the oven window
man that was in that damn tele made for
television movie well that well they
made it from this book yeah yeah I
remember that I remember that from a kid
I saw that as a kid it scared the [__]
out of me a lot of people were scared
that like yeah I remember that I've been
to I I wanted to watch it but I didn't
actually find that I didn't have time to
watch it before because I was thinking
oh maybe I should watch that but like I
ran ahead of time wouldn't mind watching
that I've seen it before but it was like
a long time yeah me too because I
remember that too when I read it I was
like oh I remember like that I remember
that seed yeah like seeing the dude's
face like his face in the microwave in
the oven the microwave oven she opens it
or something and you see it and she's
like whoa whoa yeah what the [__] yeah
didn't he have a hat on or something or
something well it's like it was supposed
to be like the captain the captain yeah
right like I think the guy she's at was
like yeah well was she the captain or
the plate uh engineer yeah but she saw
somebody like in there so she sees the
dude looking at her and then she runs
and gets another flight attendant it's
like hey come look at this [__] so
apparently that person came and said oh
my God there's like a dude the other one
apparently so uh so yeah so they both
saw this dude and uh then they go up to
the flight deck and they call the flight
engineer like come down here look at
this [__] and then so that guy comes
down and he looks at the face and he not
only like sees the face also but he's
like that's Don repo that's the flight
engineer that died on flight 401. so he
apparently like recognized him because
it had been in the thing
now apparently this image of Don repo if
that's who it was in the oven door
said watch out for fire on this airplane
and then kind of winked out of existence
right he's like warning about some [__]
now once this plane allegedly arrived in
Mexico City I'm not saying that it
allegedly arrived in Mexico City I'm
sure it did I'm just saying that
allegedly this is what happened uh it
was found out that one of the three
engines was damaged and would have to be
replaced
now
um they actually had a like a repair
crew come in and they were gonna fly it
back to for repairs like with no
passengers in it right but when they
took off one of the two engines that
remained flamed out and they had to make
an emergency landing on just one engine
so which was kind of like a big deal
now uh so they're like okay well maybe
the ghost was like warning them about
this because like a fire or something
like that now at this point like the guy
that wrote the book said that
mysteriously the cockpit voice recorder
was also when they did the repair on
this particular plane which wasn't the
same plane that crashed obviously
because that one was like pretty much
obliterated
but when they did the repair work on it
they replaced the cockpit voice recorder
which they thought was weird because I
don't think there was anything wrong
with the voice recorder
now so he starts looking into it the
author did
um and interviewed like a bunch of
Airline employees about it and according
to the flight crew the people that he
interviewed
um Don repo had actually appeared in the
cockpit
during this when this thing was
happening when they were going to take
the plane to be repaired and like the
engine flamed out and everything he had
come over the voice recorder and told
them what to do that was their story
okay so that's why they replaced the cop
I was like why would you replace it it's
like you have a helpful ghost like
telling you like how to fix [__] like if
you can why would you want to get rid of
that I don't know but yeah
now uh so as time went on
both pilots and flight attendants
reported seeing usually it was Don repo
like the flight engineer from the flight
that crashed dude I gotta say something
Jenny this case is better than the first
case
this one here's true well because I
think this one is probably like 100 more
[__] than this yeah yeah this is
more cynical it's more of like uh more
more [__] movie-like here man we
gotta see I want to see this made for TV
movie again we can watch it later if you
want if you can find it's probably
probably somebody put it on YouTube
because it was like a TV movie Yes TV
movie I remember it as a kid
I'm pretty sure yeah it was 76 17 yeah
my dad had to see it yeah yeah it was
like a big I guess it's all I gotta see
this [__] appointment TV I remember
watching it oh yeah wow I couldn't
understand I couldn't follow it all I
was a little kid but I remembered that
scene with the damn
the captain's face in the reflection of
the oven in the microwave
scared yeah and I remember it's kind of
like blue and spooky
now we're gonna have to fight it because
now I'm kind of curious like I said I
was thinking about watching it before
but I just went out of time
because I was watching like uh you got
the name of it yeah yeah okay this is
called the ghost of flight 401. okay all
right yeah it's easy it's like based on
the book okay yeah I was like I said I
was gonna watch it but I was like
watching a bunch of other documentaries
and stuff about because I got all
fascinated about flight 191 and like um
you know the the actual mechanical
difficulties and I got like all over
that but you know what I mean all right
so uh so yeah so apparently a bunch of
them saw the ghost of Don Reaper usually
Don repo sometimes they would see the
captain
like Bob Loft um sometimes too but
usually they would see the flight
engineer and usually when he would turn
up he would give them like some kind of
little warning or hey we'll may want to
check this out or like some shit's about
to go sideways or some [__] like that
um so
what ended up happening or what How The
Story Goes is that all of the flights
because it was several different flights
I believe it was the same airline or it
was the same kind of plane
and what they were able to establish was
that
um every time that somebody on the plane
saw one of these apparitions allegedly
was a plane that had parts that had
supposedly been salvaged from the
wreckage of Flight 401 like
which is crazy to me like you think it's
like they're digging through the swamp
and it's like hey we could use this
this piece of like we'll put it on this
other plane
I don't know if they would really do
that but like you know
so yeah so that was what they determined
they're like well we had pieces that
were left over from this crash and they
used them in other planes because this
was apparently like a new plane and they
didn't have enough parts or something
like that so every time they would put
one of the one of the pieces from this
crash plane into another plane people
would start seeing the dead people not
any of the passengers I don't think but
usually either the flight engineer or
the pilot like on these other planes
so um two of the main parts
that they had apparently salvaged from
the crash were uh an oven like I said
probably where why they saw the face and
that and the elevator because that
particular plane the l1011 had um lit an
elevator that went down to the galley
which was like downstairs like in the
belly of the plane
um so yeah so apparently those two parts
in particular got installed on another
of the same model plane and that was
where repo would usually like turn up
now uh so yeah so this book
was made into a TV movie as we mentioned
called The Ghost of flight 401. you're
seeing that star Shatner
wait starred the mighty Shatner does it
oh man if that's true [__] hell yeah
we're gonna see that [__] you gotta find
that [__] right now because now I kind
of want to watch it in the mood we can
we can get we can get drunker and watch
it watch it I'll make us something to
eat yeah we'll we'll make some food and
we'll get drunker and we'll watch a
plane crash for me like a ghosty plane
crash
okay let me lift this [__] up now they
now he he might be giving me a bum
steering Who Stare that was [__] who
said that mango or murder mango mango
said that he might it's probably true to
them manga said that ghost of what the
ghost of flight 401.
yeah okay so now even though it says
ghost like singular 78 yeah
okay that's it Ernest Borgnine
wow oh yeah I came back yeah
Russell God damn that's star-studded uh
Robert Howard husband was in WKRP yeah I
don't see any [__] I don't see any
[__] the [__] the chat's not in that
[__] dude manga said Shatner was in a
haunted airplane movie yeah I think
that's another one that you're thinking
of because I've seen that what the [__]
was the name of that one I just watched
it Tom Hanks is in it Hearts oh Tom
Hartley he was probably like [__]
five yeah I mean
there's a lot of no he wasn't five when
that was made he was probably like a
teenager Tina Chan Gary Lockwood
oh I know who Gary Lockwood is he was in
like some Roger Corbin movies I think
okay check it out we'll check it out
that's what happens when you're an
animal Yorkie just like you see all
these [__] horrible Roger Corbin
movies I remember all the actors let me
see if that shit's on I'm pretty sure
Gary Lockwood was in one of those
terrible sword and sorcery movies that
was on MST uh it's on YouTube
I figured it well yeah it's on YouTube I
figured it would be uh yeah what was the
one that William Shatner was in though I
feel like I just saw it not too long ago
like a year or two ago yeah it was one
that was on a plane what the [__] was it
yeah
was it haunted plane
yeah I guess it was haunted plane it's
on YouTube in the original aspect ratio
all [__] up looking okay well yeah
it's not like it's [__]
No One's Gonna Do a widescreen version
of that yeah
it's all right now I want to see it all
right we'll watch that later we'll check
it out we'll watch that after the show
we'll talk about it on the side track
show like what we thought about it
uh but yeah so so that's the movie
now um
apparently in the book
um the author uh John Fuller he wrote
that the airline was trying to like
cover all this [__] up right
um he said that every time one of the
crew or somebody like that would report
that they had seen one of the ghosts on
a on a flight and they'd put it in the
logbook I don't know why you do that but
maybe you would
um then the log book would mysteriously
be replaced with a blank logbook that
was one thing that he said in the in his
book
he also talked about this um mechanic
who see here's another thing where I
kind of feel like maybe this whole book
is [__] because he didn't name a lot
of the people because the excuse he gave
was well these people don't want to get
fired or they don't want their
reputation ruined or blah blah so nobody
used their real names you know what I
mean which
I don't know that seems a little
suspicious to me
so he just said um there's a mechanic
who wouldn't give his name and he said
that he found a whole stock room of
equipment which was all in like perfect
working order that Eastern had ordered
to be pulled out of various airplanes
and these were all the pieces that had
apparently been salvaged from the flight
that had crashed flight 401
and that included the oven and the
elevator famously but a bunch of other
pieces too now mango if you can find the
name of that Shatner [__] haunted
yeah
I just saw it yeah I mean I didn't just
see it but I saw it like recently sounds
familiar because I remember it being
like an All-Star cast and I think it was
also a TV movie like a yeah like a
disaster movie because I remember well
remember like a while back we went on
kind of like a disaster movie Kick
beside an adventure and I feel and I
feel like we watched it around that time
or maybe a little bit before that
Avalanche
Avalanche was on the new MST and that
was probably I think that was my
favorite episode of the new MST because
what a [__] the Mia Farrow was in
that yeah that was like [__]
hilarious that was like a skiing
thing y'all had to be old enough to
understand the [__] 1970s [__]
Disaster Movie and they were on
television too man everybody everybody
just wanted disasters they were
All-Stars plane crashes and building
fire like Towering Inferno that was
another one oh I don't think we saw that
one we haven't seen that recently we did
watch Poseidon Adventure and we watched
um what was the other one we watched
the the whole process the whole the
whole reason why you watch those or or
the Boomers watched them that was those
were Boomer movies okay oh yeah big time
they watched them because they wanted to
see the stars they grew up with under
pressure
okay and [__] fighting for survival
how is Ernest not gonna deal with this
situation yeah how would Ernest we want
to know
and they're all dying and a lot of them
die as Heroes and some of them dies
cowards you know just yeah well they
were cool they were cool they're like
kind of cool to the disaster flick and I
mean you know at least like some actors
that were I hate to use the word has
been because that's like a terrible term
but these were slow yeah they were like
on the downward slope of their career
they were getting a little bit older and
it's like they were getting a paycheck
and it's like they got to like have they
give us a send-off on the damn distance
be a hero like saving like some children
full of blood or some [__] like that
yeah that's nice yeah there was
something weirdly kind of like
comforting about disaster flicks movies
kind of like watching a dead Mall video
like an old dead Mall video I think you
know what I think it is I think it's
because you're watching it being like
well at least I'm not in that situation
like my life sucks but but it could be
so much worse yeah but there's something
kind of normal about them I guess
there's something kind of normal about
it yeah
I always kind of like I said I always
kind of approached them that way it's
like because no matter how much your
life sucks it's like well at least
you're not like in
uh a cruise ship that's sinking and you
have to [__] yeah and it's upside
down and you got to get to the right
because I'm like wow those people are
really [__] yeah
what am I complaining about but yeah
it's that kind of situation so so you
know that's I think that's why a lot of
people like them they're fast paced
though and they're not realistic they're
just
fun yeah fun suspense movies yeah
I think yeah I think we were thinking
about watching Towering Inferno but I
think we had to pay maybe that's what it
was and then because they had because
which means I had one of the better ones
because Amazon Prime has a bunch of them
but we were just like going through and
watching all the free ones that means
it's one of the better ones if you have
to pay
it usually is
I mean I remember that being one of the
big ones no not I mean not always
because it's like a [__] song after
it PG's did Disco Inferno
Disco Inferno is about Inferno wasn't
the Bee Gees who's it did that [__] who
did that but Disco Inferno was about
Towering Inferno it was a Towering
Inferno [__] reboot that's what it
was who did this go in front of
um oh I'm I don't remember but it sure
wasn't okay that's just that's just it
doesn't even sound like the BG's no I
just remembered it though manga put a
link there he said this is it what's
that
he sent a link to IMDb I can't click on
it because it'll [__] up my [__] oh
that's Shatner's [__] uh Ghost movie
we just I just saw it like not that long
ago I just couldn't remember like the
name of it yeah and they're talking
about Poseidon yeah because we went
through so many [__] disaster movies
but I think like and we went through
disaster movies and then I had like an
Eco horror kind of thing because I did a
video over my scare Salon where I talked
about
um what I do Kingdom of the spiders uh
food of the Gods and Empire of the ants
that's right
because those were the ones I need to do
Orca too I feel like because that was
another one I was really into when I was
a kid
that was another big thing in the 70s
was Eco horror This Disaster is an Eco
horror that was like the 70s Horror in a
nutshell
like nature is coming to get you and
also
cruise ships and buildings and planes
are coming to get you yeah okay
what's it called no I'm looking for it
but I gotta re-go go ahead okay
all right so um so yeah so this book
that he published uh about the ghost of
Flight 401 and he basically said in
there most of it is like interviews with
ostensibly like people that worked for
the company or had seen the ghost or
something like that called horror at 37
000 feet that's right
under what circumstance 1973 yeah under
what circumstances do we watched that we
must have just like come across because
I know we've saw that like really
recently
so mango said Orca is a great film I
know I always really like Dorka
and that's another one that I kind of
like want to re-watch because that's
another one that I remember from
well because you know I'm a kid and I
grew up in Central Florida and we used
to go you know we couldn't afford to go
far like on vacation so usually we would
go to Disney or we go to Sea World and
so you know I grew up like watching
Shamu and [__] like that so I was like
ooh Shamu gone bad I'm I'm down or at 37
000 feet is also on YouTube
yeah I thought it was for free yeah
I mean you we might be able to find a
better copy of it somewhere else too
like because I always like to check that
first but YouTube is like the last Last
Resort usually this usually it's [__]
got bad resolution it's not uh it's like
right off a television that's what I'm
saying it hasn't been so it's like you
should usually check like the other just
in case like check 2B check Amazon Prime
you never know because somebody if I
have a remastered version right if they
don't then you can watch it on YouTube
so so yeah so this guy writes this book
and like I said
um
all of the people in it like they were
like well we don't really want to get in
trouble we don't want any like reprisals
in case we get canned or something like
that so it's like they wouldn't really
give them their real names which like I
said seems a little suspicious
also you have to be a little bit
suspicious because the guy that wrote
this book John G Fuller
um he had also up until the time he
wrote goes to play 401 he usually wrote
UFO books like so he was like a
paranormal guy like he his actually his
best known book at the time that he
published goes to flight 401 was about
Betty and Barney Hill and it was called
the interrupted Journey
so you know that doesn't mean that he's
full of [__] but I don't know you just
have to be like really suspicious
now interestingly in 1980
Robert Serling who actually was related
to Rod Sterling I can't remember how
they were related but he wrote a book
um about the history of Eastern Airlines
and it was called from the captain to
the colonel
um so it was just about the whole
history because the airline started in
um and was actually headed by World War
one uh flying ace Captain Eddie
Rickenbacker and then The Late Late
1980s uh that when it was run by Colonel
Frank Borman who was an Apollo astronaut
now um interestingly Borman
who was the uh the head of Eastern
Airlines at the time of the disaster
was actually uh on site like in the
crash like he actually went to the crash
site and was like helping like rescue
victims and stuff
now apparently in the book
um
he
basically like the the guy that wrote
The Ghost of Flight 401 book he said
that the executives at the Eastern
Airlines had tried to basically get the
employees to shut up about the ghosts
and
the actual people that worked for
Eastern Islands were gonna Sue
but Borman who is the head of Eastern at
the time was like don't do that because
then the book will just get more
publicity so let's just like keep it on
the doubt he didn't want to do like a
stray sand effect on it you know what I
mean yeah like he didn't want to draw
more attention to it than it already had
so he's like yeah let's not do that
let's let's not sue them even though you
know
um so basically in this particular book
they did ask a lot of people who you
know were actually named and who
actually worked at the place at the time
and they said you know do you know have
you seen this ghost have you heard about
the ghost and basically
um none of them at the time said no
they're like we've heard the ghost
stories but we heard them later like you
know they didn't really know anything
about so I kind of feel like maybe this
is a case of somebody writing a book and
like
taken like a couple little things that
were going around and like just weaving
this whole like kind of book about it
and that it basically became like an
urban legend
because
um they basically the the guy that wrote
the book later it's like we went to
actual people that worked there and like
asked them if they'd ever seen the ghost
or hurt or knew anybody that seen the
ghost and all of them was said no that
they had never they didn't know what
they were talking about so I kind of
feel like this was kind of like you know
so the guy that wrote the book in 1980
he also found the whole situation
because remember what I said about the
plane like that was gonna you know the
emergency landing in Mexico City and the
ghost essentially like warned him about
it and stuff yeah and so he went and
found all the people that were actually
involved in that
and uh he said uh the the whole thing
about like the plane breaking down and
the emergency landing and all that that
did happen that's true
but
um nobody reported seeing a ghost in an
oven before that like he's like I
couldn't find any evidence of that
Hugo's asking mango about horror 37 000
feet which is the
uh William Shatner haunted airplane
movie asking him how good that movie was
and mango says that's very good
I remember liking it yeah
not long ago we'll put that on the list
well let me write that down okay so we
got
the one we're gonna watch tonight and
then we'll watch horror at 37 000 feet I
want to see that
I vaguely remember that horror 37 000
feet I vaguely remember I mean I'm
pretty sure we watched it we were kids
when that [__] came out you know I mean
it was like 73 and they were doing this
reruns you know and by the time 76 77 I
vaguely remembered that one but I think
that was a pretty big movie
uh but at least on the rerun scene on
television back in mid 70s by the time
VHS came out that [__] was long for god
well it's crazy because in the 70s I
mean if like I said people had like
appointment TV you know I mean it's like
something was coming on yeah you had to
watch it you had to watch it you
couldn't tape it right you couldn't
watch it later yeah you had to [__]
see it if you missed it you [__]
missed it yeah and what was funny is
that for you youngsters
because we were babies when this year
was going just like grandparents yeah
we're gonna sound like people's
grandparents we were babies when this
[__] was going off
those movies like the appointment TV
she's talking about I remember my dad's
oh no that's just coming on we gotta say
it's like they're getting food ready and
everything it's like a big deal yeah
like I said it was like like go into a
show like going to the movies because
like I said you were you if you missed
it you missed it yeah and they were like
big budget and people were like oh man
that was great
now they're watching this through CRT
television so it was low res
you weren't sure how well how good it
was actually filmed or videotaped you
didn't know but it was a good television
experience I remember people the adults
just enjoying the [__] out of it well
and the thing is like if you don't
really expect any better from TV yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it was like a TV event
I remember when Poseidon Adventure was
on when it was kind of coming out on
television when they that might have
been another appointment TV I don't know
if that was a movie or a TV or whatever
well Poseidon Adventure played in the
theater did it play it a few when it
came out on TV that was another
appointment yeah everybody had to see
that
this is all pre-star wars you know what
I mean so people were not spoiled yet
with special effects even though the
special effects are pretty good on
Poseidon Adventure for what it is
but I remember everybody getting the TV
dinners and the TV trays out [__] you
know get oh tonight Poseidon Adventures
gonna be oh we gotta watch that you know
but you know just the way it was back
then it's another era Trey says someone
get Jenny to look at the comments what
it was the Twilight Zone episode chat
was in guys well I know he was in he was
in well he was in the one with the you
know man on the wing of the plane that's
not what he's talking that's not what
Meg was talking about no it's a movie
I've seen it yeah Meg was talking about
another movie about a haunted airplane
called horror at 37 000 feet you can
watch it free on YouTube and it's got
Shatner wait a second was it a haunted
airplane or was there like I think it's
a haunted airport I want to say it was
like a cult wasn't it a cult in the
blade oh what according to Mega it was a
haunted airplane and it looked I thought
it was like a cult we'll see we'll see I
don't know why that just occurs to me
because like I said I remember watching
it not too long ago like I know
everybody knows about like the that was
Nightmare at 37 000 feet or whatever it
was that was the Twilight the chat did a
lot of [__] cult horror flicks he did
that one where he was out there in the
[__] old west talking to the devil
the devil's Reign Devil's Reign which is
that also had Earnest Ernest it was
actually a good movie in goat horns yeah
Anton I like that movie yeah Tom Levy
was involved I really like that movie
yeah he was he was a consultant on it
he's in it for like a second yeah it's a
good movie but yeah good movie for its
time you know you watch it now and
you're like what John Travolta was in
that [__] too yeah that's like five
seconds that's right that's right yeah
like sorry that was like his first maybe
his first movie role I'm not really sure
like you can't tell it's Sam I don't
think satanic cult movie yeah in the old
way oh that was another thing that was
big in the 70s satanic movies yeah there
was a lot of those and it's taking it
taking place in an abandoned old west
Ghost Town more yes yeah yeah we
reviewed that yeah we enjoyed it I've
I've always really had decent special
effects for the time and good acting and
Earnest point I think Ernest was as cool
as a goat man yeah I think he feels cool
kills it is [__] I don't know Satan
or a co-leader kind of deal
it's hard to tell he was a possessed
cult leader he I guess became satanic
people melted and [__] like that it was
crazy yeah mango says Shatner plays the
pilot not a cult on the plane has some
devilish stuff involved okay okay maybe
that's what I'm we'll see it we'll see
it mango said race with the Devil is
amazing oh yeah that's another good one
yeah we reviewed that one a while back
too I think we did it as a double
feature with the car these [__] all
went down in American history and the
car I think kicked that [__] off it
might have actually been it might have
been could have been Spielberg and
[__] duel kicked off which was
actually based on a Richard Mathis right
and then the duel wasn't Satan no but I
think the Dual [__] I think duel
kicked off the [__] I think that
actually kicked off [__] the car
which is well the Titanic version of The
Duel and then the Satan thing started to
come out and there was a lots of those
well the Satan thing started with
Rosemary's Baby yeah okay and that was
nice that was 1960 something so they see
so there's they Blended the two they
Blended and then The Exorcist was 1973.
yeah so there was like a big late 60s
early 70s they were trying and the
Manson Murders that was 1916. that was
the time for sake
that was another thing that's every time
I think of the 70s I was thinking like
yeah satanic cult movies disaster movies
and Eco horror and then by the time the
early 80s like quit putting mercury in
the rivers you're making [__] giant
bear monsters and then late 70s early
80s the evil came out which was Satan in
a house that was good too
it was good I like that one well and
then like I said late 70s and 80s that
was all like slasher movies then well it
wasn't all flasher movies but that was
like the big thing the Legacy witches
that was also 78 was it yeah I think so
I think Legacy was Great Masterpiece
Mega says frogs
frogs was the [__] we did I think we
did that yeah we did yes that was
another Eco horror yeah the weird thing
about frogs is that it's like not
entirely about frogs it's about like all
the animals get mad and like [__] with
us not just frogs it was frogs and
butterflies and snakes and alligators
and Eagles and I agree with mango that
[__] uh the car was better than duel
I think it was
spookier yeah I get yeah I get that it's
the devil's car it's killing people look
let's finish Jewel was more like it was
just psychos like the hitch like The
Hitcher yeah yeah yeah
psychos out in the desert it's trying to
get you like for some reason like I said
if I'm even though I don't usually I
don't believe in paranormal [__]
if a movie is gonna scare me it'll
usually be like creepy mysterious
paranormal-ish kind of [__] like movies
that are about things that could really
happen like hey there's some just human
psycho like following me in a car or you
know it's a serial killer or something
like I'll enjoy those but they don't
scare me and I don't know why that is
because that [__] could really happen I
absolutely know about the Paranormal but
I don't believe the Paranormal Tales
told by Hollywood big difference
and then the fakers and [__]
the real [__] is like what we talked
about before you guys know me yeah it's
out there Jenny's seen it
he go says Christine Christie yeah yeah
that's a great car that's a great card
that's a great well it's a great car but
it's also great yeah that was 83 though
uh Senor sticks just got here oh my God
all right we're so drunk already but I
gotta make us something to eat here soon
how much is left on this just like a
tiny amount a tiny amount okay what I
was basically gonna say is that the
whole I hate to like burst everyone's
bubble but the whole ghost of foro uh
flight 401 thing probably just came from
that book because a lot of the stuff
that people talk about nowadays like all
like oh I saw the face in the oven and
stuff just came from that book and the
book came out four years after the
actual incident and when they did like
interviews with actual people that were
actually on the plane or like actually
like knew anything about it like um
nobody really they didn't know anything
about that know much about it though
like they'd heard the stories they're
like yeah we don't that was like kind of
[__] the stories happened after and
the thing about it too is that one of
the things
um that probably
here's probably what kicked off the
whole thing
so remember how I said like the guy that
wrote the book Sterling
um in 1980. he found out the whole like
Mexico City playing thing he's like yeah
they really did have to do an emergency
landing and it was [__] up and
everything like that but then like he
found it later on that it's like nobody
really said that they'd seen anybody's
ghost like warning him about it or not
so
um what ended up happening though he
found out that after this incident like
after the emergency landing there was a
party
and somebody asked one of the pilots at
the party like that it had to do it oh
how how did that feel to have to land
that plane with only one engine
and the guy jokingly said oh it was
really scary for a minute I thought Don
repo's ghost was on the plane that's
what he said like he made a joke Oh I
thought it was a ghost on the plane like
[__] you know what I mean and I kind
of feel like because he said that and
that was publicized
somebody took that and ran with it and
made the whole it just really kind of
seemed like that okay that really does
seem like just maybe where this whole
story came from yeah well I mean that's
kind of what they're thinking that's
where they've traced it back to because
that guy said that and that was reported
in the media that he made that joke
um so somebody's like hey got an idea
because like I said it was four years
like when the book came out but the
thing about it though is that
the whole thing about the ghost
appearing
on later flights that had salvaged
pieces from the crashed Airline
that is actually not true
because the flight that crashed into the
Everglades
um nothing was salvaged from that plane
um they're like they they wouldn't have
installed even if anything had survived
from that crash that was like instilled
in good enough shape they would not have
installed that into another plane yeah
and um that's just not the procedure
they would not do that and they're like
and anyway like nothing was in good
enough shape to have put into another
plane you know what I mean and
um I was reading on uh skeptoid or
something like that they said basically
just do a Google image search and I do
this because it's pretty [__] up but
they're like doing image search for
flight 401 wreckage and they're like you
will see from the photos that there is
absolutely nothing that they could have
salvaged from that [__] because it was
just
it was just [__] complete wreckage so
there's like there's no way that they
would have played hey this this you know
oven still looks good let's stick this
on another plane we wouldn't do that as
soon as I heard you say that I'm looking
at that [__] sideways because I'm saying
right how contractors no they wouldn't
do that because they would those
companies are trying to supply [__] and
they're like oh well [__] that man we
talking about we got a whole new plane
buy it buy two whole new planes at a
discounted rate to replace that one but
they're going to be wheeling and dealing
they don't give a [__] about some fuel
injector or this and that that's all
that's right it's not I mean the
insurance wrote all that [__] off yeah
these are Big like billion dollars yeah
yeah they're not broke ass [__]
like me that are like looking it's like
hey that couch looks pretty good yeah
that's worth a thousand on the side of
the road yeah no it's not like that
maybe I could fix that leg that's all
walking yeah they're not doing no
they're being like well look look man
that's all written off that's gone
Insurance got that this and that look
and and the dealers are saying they'll
give us a better plan the better plane
and a better price we're gonna go go
with that one no they buy that [__] as a
[__] they don't salvage parts out of
wrecks
and I mean yeah the infrastructure isn't
there right the only thing that would
happen with that wreck is that people
[__] scavenge you for [__] uh uh
uh uh
aluminum would show up and try to pick
up as much aluminum as they can they're
like yeah seven thousand pounds of
aluminum God damn that's [__] two
that's two grand let's get the that's
three thousand dollars let's get this
[__] out of here you know that's what
they would do I mean Senor stick says
Jenny they do recycle plain metal in
Parts yeah the metal yeah the metal and
stuff yeah but I'm just saying I the the
whole Crux of this story was like they
took actual part like the oven or the
elevator yeah from this crash and like
stuck it in another plane and I don't
think they would do that no there's
[__] planes sitting on Lots ready to
be sold and these those companies had
all kinds of money and great credit
lines they just get into the plane
yeah I just kind of feel like that's not
yeah you know but like I said this this
uh this oven looks still looks pretty
good no you can barely see The Scrappers
would show up scrap all that just for
the price of the metal
that's what happened yeah I mean pretty
much but uh because it would be the
cleanup Guru right all right but uh yeah
so
basically happily
um if anything like this can be happy
the thing about it is that usually that
you can [__] on the airlines all you
want but usually when a real big
disaster like this happens they usually
do get on top of it and be like okay
what caused that let's make sure that
that doesn't happen again so after this
happened
um they did uh kind of install a bunch
of new rules a bunch of new safety
protocols and stuff like that
um they actually gave people flashlights
as standard equipment which actually
hadn't been prior to this it was 1972
for Christ's sake which is 50 years ago
um the flight attendants have to have
shoulder harnesses uh you know which
they hadn't had before
um they have to have uh they've
installed new things where the um
there'd be like an audio thing like
warning you in the autopilot [__] was
changed so they had that uh stuff as
well and you know so they did a lot of
others like safety measures like after
this after they had figured out like
what went wrong so you know it did have
a silver lining even though a lot of
people had to [__] die to do it but
you know it's a cool Ghost Story and
everything and it made like a cool book
and a cool movie which we're gonna watch
after the show yeah but I'm not entirely
sure if it really has sounds like it's
been fabricated now the first one that
we talked about flight 191 um that one
like I said I don't really believe in
ghosts but that sounds that sounds more
likely to me because they didn't really
report
I don't know it just seemed more than
anything plausible it wasn't anything
outrageous is what they reported yeah
the only thing the only the thing that
gets me is that
according to the stories the police said
people called them and said hey like
people are knocking on the windows and
doors and apparently it happened a bunch
whether or not the police actually
said that we don't we don't really know
I'm hiccuping like a [__] drunk
um like you're drunk like I'm drunk I am
drunk I got [__] I gotta do but um if we
could verify whether or not the police
actually did say that that would that
would uh if they actually did say that
that would add some credibility to the
story yeah which maybe they did maybe
they didn't but there doesn't seem to be
a way to verify that not over this span
of time
that was a long time ago
everybody involved with that case is
dead well I don't know about that it was
only in 1979 but yeah a lot of people
involved with UFO cases of the late 80s
are now dead isn't that that's true yeah
I mean if you were like older when you
started out yeah yeah because I was
saying it's like yeah they're in their
40s and 50s then right so yeah you're
gonna be dead now like some of some of
the cool UFO cases like uh UFO over
Illinois you know the black triangle
cases yeah we did a show about that
those cops were in their mid-30s a lot
of them are dead now not spooky yeah
yeah well
[Laughter]
they just die of [__] things no yeah
they die of things they die of days
things happen thank you Tom that was
very insightful
people die of things no thanks Tom Ross
[__] I put that [__] on a shirt you're a
[__] genius you might [__] die of
a thing something will make you die look
man we get out of here [__] all right
let me get out of here all right all
right we're gonna wrap this up because
we've been going for like three hours
about Steven seagalog look man I just
watched look they're talking about
bringing up cigar I just watched um
[__] uh Expendables three
oh is that what that left yeah [__] was
the unreaded the unrated cut I love the
unrated cut I've never seen the
theatrical cut all right I've never seen
the theatrical cuts of any of these I
always watch the already because I
[__] love all three of those movies
turns out
Expendables four thank you mango thank
you very much man drink it drunk is cool
yeah thank you turns out
Expendables for
has Steven Seagal in it
wait has that come out yet it's coming
out at the end of this year they're
filming no uh yes Steven Seagal is in
Expendables are they teasing us
according to according to google Steven
Seagal's in that [__]
are they gonna make fun of him the whole
time because I might actually watch
they're gonna do something crazy with
him okay
I thought he didn't have a sense of
humor though the last I saw of Seagal
online
this is like from like material from
like a year or two ago I think based on
what I saw Seagal has embraced his meme
okay that he that
all right he knows that everybody knows
he's very full of [__] that he's full of
[__] yeah he decided he's going to lean
into it I think he's leading it that is
probably the best thing that's the best
thing he should do although it's much
funnier he's well see the thing about it
Steven Seagal is kind of in an
impossible position because the reason
he became a meme in the first place was
because he was taking himself so
seriously which was hilarious yeah now
if he's in on the joke it's not really
as funny anymore I think he's kind of
leaned into it like yeah yeah it was
[__] it's not really as funny
anymore like I said it's kind of the
whole it's kind of the whole it's the
same conundrum that you fall into with
the like the so it's the so good it's
bad movie yeah or the so bad it's good
movie is that like if you're trying to
make something bad then it's not funny
but it's like if you're trying to make
something good and you fail
spectacularly then it's hilarious yeah
and I kind of feel like that's what
we're working with so I don't know how
it's gonna go now that he's actually
realized that everyone's actually
laughing at him and not with him and
he's like okay I'm gonna lean into that
but now it's not gonna be funny anymore
because it's like the whole thing that
was funny was that he thought he took
himself so seriously
the thing about Seagal is that Seagal
could have had a much more successful
career had he had a sense of humor
the problem with his movies is not that
they're bad is that the problem with his
movies is that they're boring and that
he's not actually in them and boring is
the worst thing and that he's not
actually in like I said if you're gonna
make a bad movie Just Go all in it make
it the worst [__] movie you can
possibly make I think he could have had
a really [__] cool career just
entertained made a bunch of entertaining
shitty [__] flicks where he was
actually in them instead of you having
other people do his voice other people
dubbed his voice other people walk up
and down the stairs with him so they
don't see how fat he is he should have
just been like that have been the fat
action star
he had a he has a [__] hardcore fan
following he does
and that's what he should have done you
know
they got dudes that look just like him
that love him they want to see him as
the action film I mean a lot of horrible
shitty people have fan following yeah
that doesn't really mean anything but
you know what I mean all right let's go
ahead and shut this down Jim we'll
[__] call it a night and I'll go make
us something to eat all right so we're
gonna go eat something and we're gonna
watch The Ghost of flavor yeah yeah I
want to see that yeah we'll see how that
goes if I can stay awake yeah I might
fall asleep in the middle of it because
like you know yeah because uh but you
know this is uh kind of been a fun show
so all right we will be back uh we're
gonna take tomorrow off to recover and
then on Friday we'll do our Side Tracks
show talking about whatever the hell we
feel like talking about so that'll be
fun so thank you everybody for dropping
by this evening thank you for super
chats remember we also have super thanks
if you couldn't make it for the live
stream so you could just like give us a
little tip right there it's like a
little heart with a [__] money sign
in it or something like that I don't
remember what it looks like but uh but
yeah some tips [__]
for us entertaining you getting getting
drunk and being stupid for your getting
drunk with us all right and we'll see
you guys again on Friday night good
night